[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to this video tutorial on
machine learning crash course by simply
learn
in this crash course you will learn
about the basics of machine learning and
the various applications of machine
learning
you will understand the different types
of machine learning and several
algorithms used in machine learning
for this crash course we have our
experienced instructors rahul and
richard who will take you through the
various topics of machine learning
they'll help you understand the
different classification regression and
clustering algorithms with hands-on demo
in python
some of the algorithms covered in this
crash course are logistic regression
support vector machines and random
forest to name a few in the end
we'll talk about machine learning
engineer's salary roles and
responsibilities you will learn these in
4 hours
so without any further delay let's get
started but before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update from simply learn
we know humans learn from their past
experiences
and machines follow instructions given
by humans
but what if humans can train the
machines to learn from their past data
and do what humans can do
and much faster well that's called
machine learning but it's a lot more
than just learning
it's also about understanding and
reasoning so today
we will learn about the basics of
machine learning
so that's paul he loves listening to new
songs
he either likes them or dislikes them
paul decides this
on the basis of the song's tempo genre
intensity and the gender of voice for
simplicity
let's just use tempo and intensity for
now so here
tempo is on the x-axis ranging from
relaxed to fast
whereas intensity is on the y-axis
ranging from light
to soaring we see that paul likes the
song with
fast tempo and soaring intensity while
he dislikes the song
with relaxed tempo and light intensity
so now we know paul's choices
let's say paul listens to a new song
let's name it as song a
song a has fast tempo and a soaring
intensity so it lies
somewhere here looking at the data can
you guess whether paul will like the
song
or not correct so paul likes this song
by looking at paul's past choices
we were able to classify the unknown
song very easily
right let's say now paul listens to a
new song
let's label it as song b so song b
lies somewhere here with medium tempo
and medium intensity neither relaxed nor
fast
neither light nor soaring now can you
guess whether paul likes it or not
not able to guess whether paul will like
it or dislike it
are the choices unclear correct we could
easily classify song a
but when the choice became complicated
as in the case of song b
yes and that's where machine learning
comes in let's see how
in the same example for song b if you
draw a circle around the song b
we see that there are four words for
like whereas
one word for dislike if we go for the
majority votes
we can say that paul will definitely
like the song that's all this was a
basic machine learning algorithm also
it's called k nearest neighbors so this
is just a small example
in one of the many machine learning
algorithms quite easy
right believe me it is but what happens
when the choices become complicated as
in the case of song b
that's when machine learning comes in it
learns the data builds the prediction
model
and when the new data point comes in it
can easily predict for it
more the data better the model higher
will be the accuracy
there are many ways in which the machine
learns
it could be either supervised learning
unsupervised learning
or reinforcement learning let's first
quickly understand supervised
learning suppose your friend gives you
one million coins of
three different currencies say one rupee
one euro and one dirham
each coin has different weights for
example a coin of one rupee weighs three
grams
one euro weighs seven grams and one
dirham weighs four grams
your model will predict the currency of
the coin here
your weight becomes the feature of coins
while currency
becomes the label when you feed this
data to the machine learning model
it learns which feature is associated
with which label for example
it will learn that if a coin is of three
grams it will be a one rupee coin let's
give a new coin to the machine on the
basis of the weight
of the new coin your model will predict
the currency hence
supervised learning uses labeled data to
train the model here the machine
knew the features of the object and also
the labels associated with those
features
on this note let's move to unsupervised
learning and see the difference
suppose you have cricket data set of
various players with their respective
scores
and wickets taken when you feed this
data set to the machine
the machine identifies the pattern of
player performance
so it plots this data with the
respective wickets on the x-axis
while runs on the y-axis while looking
at the data you will clearly see
that there are two clusters the one
cluster are the players
who scored higher runs and took less
wickets while the other cluster
is of the players who scored less runs
but took many wickets
so here we interpret these two clusters
as batsmen
and bowlers the important point to note
here is that there were no labels of
batsmen
and bowlers hence the learning with
unlabeled data
is unsupervised learning so we saw
supervised learning where the data was
labeled
and the unsupervised learning where the
data was unlabeled
and then there is reinforcement learning
which is a reward based learning or we
can say that it works on the principle
of feedback
here let's say you provide the system
with an image of a dog and ask it to
identify it the system
identifies it as a cat so you give a
negative feedback to the machine
saying that it's a dog's image the
machine will learn from the feedback and
finally if it comes across
any other image of a dog it will be able
to classify it correctly
that is reinforcement learning to
generalize machine learning model
let's see a flowchart input is given to
a machine learning model which then
gives the output according to the
algorithm applied
if it's right we take the output as a
final result
else we provide feedback to the training
model and ask it
to predict until it learns i hope you've
understood supervised and unsupervised
learning
so let's have a quick quiz you have to
determine whether the given scenarios
uses supervised or unsupervised learning
simple right
scenario one facebook recognizes your
friend in a picture from an
album of tagged photographs
scenario two netflix recommends new
movies based on someone's past movie
choices
scenario 3 analyzing bank data for
suspicious transactions
and flagging the fraud transactions
think wisely and comment below your
answers
moving on don't you sometimes wonder how
is machine learning possible in today's
era well that's because today we have
humongous
data available everybody's online either
making a transaction
or just surfing the internet and that's
generating a huge amount of data every
minute
and that data my friend is the key to
analysis
also the memory handling capabilities of
computers have largely increased which
helps them to process such
huge amount of data at hand without any
delay and yes
computers now have great computational
powers so there are a lot of
applications of machine learning out
there
to name a few machine learning is used
in healthcare where diagnostics are
predicted for doctor's review the
sentiment analysis that the tech giants
are doing on social media is another
interesting application of machine
learning fraud detection in the finance
sector and also to predict customer
churn in the e-commerce sector
while booking a gap you must have
encountered surge pricing
often where it says the fair of your
trip has been updated
continue booking yes please i'm getting
late for office
well that's an interesting machine
learning model
which is used by global taxi giant uber
and others
where they have differential pricing in
real time based on demand
the number of cars available bad weather
rush r
etc so they use the surge pricing model
to ensure that those who need a cab can
get one
also it uses predictive modeling to
predict
where the demand will be high with the
goal that drivers can take care of the
demand and surge pricing can be
minimized
great hey siri can you remind me to book
a cab at 6 00 pm today
okay i'll remind you thanks no problem
comment below some interesting everyday
examples around you
where machines are learning and doing
amazing jobs
so that's all for machine learning
basics today from my site keep watching
this space for more interesting videos
until then happy learning simply learn
welcomes you
to machine learning versus deep learning
versus
artificial intelligence some of the most
exciting technologies
evolving in today's world my name is
richard kirschner and i'll be hosting
this talk or
simply learn before we start covering
the basics
of these three topics and how they
connect and how they are different
let's just look at a few examples so we
get an understanding of what's going on
here's an example of artificial
intelligence in today's world
amazon echo amazon echo is a wonderful
tool
we can go in there and you can say hey
alexa what's the temperature in chicago
and the amazon echo then translates that
into zeros and ones and something the
computer understands
then it comes in and processes that
information to identify what you're
asking and what you need and where to
get that information
and then it comes back and says the
current temperature in chicago is six
degrees fahrenheit or whatever
it is at the moment so this is a
wonderful example of
artificial intelligence that we're using
right now today where that's at
as far as a commercial deployment
machine learning
a machine learning example out there is
google you're on your google search
engine it comes up you spend a lot of
time on the first link you come into and
you read the page
and google looks at that and says okay
he spent five minutes on this
let's give it a thumbs up and then you
go to the second page and the third page
you just kind of skip over them and
glance at them for a couple seconds
and google says i wasn't interested in
those pages let's give them a thumbs
down
so this is a good example of machine
learning as it starts guessing what you
like
and what you don't like so it gives you
more information along what you're going
to read and actually use
and then we have an example of deep
learning
in this example we have a black and
white image
it comes into in this case a neural
network
some people like to call it a magic box
because you really it's hard to follow
all that's going on in there there's
all these different weights and
connections and nodes
and then it comes out and colors the
beach ball
the people the background what's going
on in here is the black and white image
goes into this neural network
and before it's ever gone in the neural
network has looked at all these
different pictures on the web
or wherever it pulls the data from and
it's already
itemized them and kind of separated them
that we have some that look like beach
balls we have some that look like people
and it programs that so that when the
black and white image comes in it goes
okay that piece right there
resembles this and all these other
photos
and the network is able to identify that
and then color the beach ball with the
colors
that you see on there so it gives it
this is really wonderful because they
did a wonderful job
coloring this picture and that's the
full setup is where the deep learning
example comes in and they usually center
around
neural networks so we looked at a few
examples
what's in it for you first we're going
to talk about human versus
artificial intelligence this is very
important because
this is our marker we as humans are
amazing and so we want to understand
how artificial intelligence compares and
what it does that it can accelerate
above humans and how it can integrate
with the human experience
what is machine learning and deep
learning all about are they really all
that different
we'll have a few more examples in here
and then we'll talk a little bit about
types of ai and machine learning
and comparing machine learning and deep
learning and finally a glimpse into the
future
human versus artificial intelligence
humans are amazing let's just face it
we're amazing creatures
we're all over the planet we're
exploring
every nic chinook we've gone to the moon
we've gone into outer space we're just
amazing creatures
we're able to use the available
information to make decisions
to communicate with other people
identify patterns and data
remember what people have said adapt to
new situations
so let's take a look at this so you can
get a picture you're a human being so
you know it's like to be human
let's take a look at artificial
intelligence versus the human
artificial intelligence develops
computer systems that can accomplish
texts that require
human intelligence so we're looking at
this
one of the things that computers can do
they can provide more accurate results
this is very important recently i did a
project
on cancer whereas identifying markers
and as a human being you look at that
and you might be
looking at all the different images and
the data that comes off of them
and say i like this person so i want to
give them a very good
outlook and the next person you might
not like so you want to give a bad
outlook
well with artificial intelligence you're
going to get a consistent
prediction of what's going to come out
interacts with humans using their
natural language
we've seen that as probably the biggest
development feature right now that's in
the commercial market that everybody
gets to use
as we saw with the example of alexa they
learn from their mistakes and adapt to
new environments
so we see this slowly coming in more and
more
and they learn from the data and
automate repetitive learning
repetitive learning has a lot to do with
the neural networks
you have to program thousands upon
thousands of pictures in there
and it's all automated so as today's
computers evolve
it's very quick and easy and affordable
to do this
what is machine learning and deep
learning all about
imagine this say you had some time to
waste not that any of us really have a
lot of time anymore to just waste in
today's world
and you're sitting by the road and you
have a whole lot of and a whole lot of
time passes by
there's a few hours and suddenly you
wonder
how many cars buses trucks and so on
passed by
in the six hours now chances are you're
not going to sit by the road for six
hours and count buses cars and trucks
unless you're working for the city and
you're trying to do city planning and
you want to know
hey do we need to add a new truck route
maybe we need a bicycle length we have a
lot of bicyclists here
that kind of thing so maybe city
planning would be great for this
machine learning well the way machine
learning works is we
have labeled data with features okay
so you have a truck or a car a
motorcycle a bus or a bicycle
and each one of those are labeled it
comes in
and based on those labels and comparing
those features
it gives you an answer it's a bicycle
it's a truck it's a motorcycle
this is a little bit more in depth on
this and the model here
it actually the features we're looking
at would be like the tires
someone sits there and figures out what
a tire looks like
it takes a lot of work if you try to try
to figure the difference between a car
tire a bicycle tire a motorcycle tire
so in the machine learning field this
could take a long time if you're going
to do
each individual aspect of a car
and try to get a result on there and
that's what they did do there was a
very this is still used on smaller
amounts of data
where you figure out what those features
are and then you label them
deep learning so with deep learning
one of our solutions is to take a very
large unlabeled data set
and we put that into a training model
using artificial neural networks
and then that goes into the neural
network itself when we create a neural
network
and you'll see the arrows are actually
kind of backward but
which actually is a nice point because
when we train the neural network
we put the bicycle in and then it comes
back and says if it's a truck
it comes back and says well you need to
change that to bicycle
and then it changes all those weights
going backward they call it back
propagation
and let it know it's a bicycle and
that's how it learns
once you've trained the neural network
you then put the new data
in and they call this testing the models
you need to have some data you've kept
off to the side where you know the
answer to
and you take that and you provide the
required output and you say okay is this
is this neural network working correctly
did it identify a bike as a bike
a truck as a truck a motorcycle as a
motorcycle
let's just take a little closer look at
that determining what objects are
present in the data so how does deep
learning
do this and here we have the image of
the bike it's
28 by 28 pixels that's a lot of
information there could you imagine
trying to guess that this is a bicycle
image
by looking at each one of those pixels
and trying to figure out what's around
it
and we actually do that as human beings
it's pretty amazing we know what a
bicycle
is and even though it comes in as all
this information and what this looks
like
is the image comes in it converts it
into
a bunch of different nodes in this case
there's a lot more than what they show
here
and it goes through these different
layers and out comes and says okay this
is a bicycle
a lot of times they call this the magic
black box why
because as we watch it go across here
all these
weights and all the math behind this and
it's not
it's a little complicated on the math
side you really don't need to know that
when you're programming or doing working
with the deep learning
but it's like magic you don't know you
really can't figure out what's going to
come out by looking what's in each one
of those dots and each one of those
lines are firing and what's going in
between them
so we like to call it the magic box so
that's where deep learning comes in
and in the end it comes up and you have
this whole neural network comes up and
says okay
we fire all these different pixels and
we connects all these different dots
and gives them different weights and
says okay this is a bicycle
and that's how we determine what the
object is present in the data
with deep learning machine learning
we're going to take a step into machine
learning here and you'll see how these
fit together in a minute
the system is able to make predictions
or take decisions based on
past data that's very important for
machine learning
is that we're looking at stuff and based
on what's been there before
we're creating a decision on there we're
creating something out of there
we're coloring a beach ball we're
telling you what the weather is
in chicago what's nice about machine
learning is
a very powerful processing capability
it's quick and accurate outcomes
so you get results right away once you
program the system
the results are very fast and the
decisions
and predictions are better they're more
accurate they're consistent
you can analyze very large amounts of
data
some of these data things that they're
analyzing now are petabytes and
terabytes of data
it would take hundreds of people
hundreds of years to go through some of
this data and do the same thing that the
machine learning can do in a very short
period of time
and it's inexpensive compared to hiring
hundreds of people so it becomes a very
affordable way to move into the future
is to apply the machine learning
to whatever businesses you're working on
and deep learning systems think and
learn like humans
using artificial neural networks again
it's like a magic box
performance improves with more data so
the more data the deep learning gets
the more it gives you better results
it's scalability
so you can scale it up you can scale it
down you can increase
what you're looking at currently you
know we're limited by the amount of
computer processing power as to how big
that can get
but that envelope continually gets
pushed every day on what it can do
problem solved in an end-to-end method
so instead of having to break it apart
and you have the first piece coming in
and you identify
tires and the second piece is
identifying
labeling handlebars and then you bring
that together that if it has handlebars
and tires it's a bicycle
and if it has something that looks like
a large square it's probably a truck
the neural networks does this all in one
network you don't really know what's
going on in all those weights
and all those little bubbles but it does
it pretty much
in one package that's why the neural
network systems are so big nowadays and
coming in to their own
best features are selected by the system
and it this is important they kind of
put
it's on a bullet on the side here it's a
subset of
machine learning this is important we
talk about deep learning
it is a form of machine learning there's
lots of other forms of machine learning
data analysis but this is the newest and
biggest thing that they apply to a lot
of different packages
and they use all the other machine
learning tools available
to work with it and it's very fast to
test
you put in your information you then
have your group of
tests and then you held some aside you
see how does it do it's very quick to
test it and see what's going on with
your deep learning in your neural
network
are they really all that different
ai versus machine learning versus deep
learning
concepts of ai so we have concepts of
iii
you'll see natural language processing
machine learning an approach to create
artificial intelligence
so it's one of the subsets of artificial
intelligence
knowledge representation automated
reasoning computer vision
robotics machine learning versus ai
versus deep learning or
ai and machine learning and deep
learning
so we look at this we have ai with
machine learning and
deep learning and so we're going to put
them all together we find out that ai is
the big picture
we have a collection of books it goes
through some deep learning
the digital data is analyzed text mining
comes through the particular book you're
looking for maybe it's a
genre books is identified and in this
case uh we have a robot that goes and
gives a book to the patron
i have yet to be at a library that has a
robot bring me a book but that will be
cool when it happens
as we look at some of the pieces here
this information goes into
uh there's as far as this example the
translation of the handwritten printed
data to digital form
that's pretty hard to do that's pretty
hard to go in there and translate
hundreds and hundreds of books and
understand
what they're trying to say if you've
never read them
so in this case we use the deep learning
because you can already use
examples where they've already
classified a lot of books and then they
can compare those texts and say
oh okay this is a book on automotive
repair this is a book
on robotic building the digital data is
in
analyzed then we have more text mining
using machine learning
so maybe we'd use a different program to
do a basic
classify what you're looking for and say
oh you're looking for
auto repair and computers so you're
looking for automated cars
once it's identified then of course it
brings you the book
so here's a nice summation of what we
were just talking about ai
with machine learning and deep learning
deep learning is a subset of machine
learning which is a subset of artificial
intelligence
so you can look at artificial
intelligence as the big picture how does
this compare to the human experience
in either doing the same thing as a
human we do
or it does it better than us
and machine learning which has a lot of
tools
is something that learns from data past
experiences
it's programmed it's uh comes in there
and it says hey
we already had these five things happen
the sixth one should be about the same
and then there's a lot of tools in
machine learning but deep learning then
is a very specific tool in machine
learning
it's the artificial neural network which
handles large amounts of data
and is able to take huge pools of
experiences
pictures and ideas and bring them
together
real life examples artificial
intelligence
news generation very common nowadays as
it goes through there and finds the news
articles or generates the news based
upon
the news feeds or the back-end coming in
and says okay
let's give you the actual news based on
this there's all the
different things amazon echo they have a
number of different prime music
on there of course there's also the
google command
and there's also cortana there's tons
of smart home devices now where we can
ask it to turn the tv on
or play music for us that's all
artificial intelligence from
front to back you're having a human
experience
with these computers and these
objects that are connected to the
processing machine learning
uh spam detection very common machine
learning
doesn't really have the human
interaction part
so this is the part where it goes and
says okay that's a spam that's not a
spam
and it puts it in your spam folder
search engine result refining
another example of machine learning
whereas it looks at your different
results
and it go and it is able to categorize
them as far as i said the most hits
this is the least viewed this has five
stars
you know however they want to weight it
all exactly good examples of machine
learning
and then the deep learning uh deep
learning another example is
as you have like a exit sign in this
case is translating it into
french sorti i hope i said that right
neural network has been programmed with
all these different words and images and
so it's able to
look at the exit in the middle and it
goes okay we want to know what that is
in french and it's able to push that out
in france
french and learn how to do that
and then we have chat bots i remember
when microsoft first had their little
paper clip
boy that was like a long time ago they
came up and you would type in there and
chat with it
these are growing you know it's nice to
just be able to ask a question
and it comes up and gives you the answer
and instead of it being
were you just doing a search on certain
words
it's now able to start linking those
words together and form a sentence
in that chat box types of ai and machine
learning
types of artificial intelligence this in
the next few slides are really important
so one of the types of artificial
intelligence is reactive machines
systems that only react they don't form
memories they don't have past
experiences they have something that
happens to them and they react to it
my washing machine is one of those if i
put a ton of clothes in it and it all
clumped on one side
it automatically adds a weight to
recenter it
so that my washing machine is actually a
reactive machine working with whatever
the load is and keeps it nice and so
when it spins it doesn't go
thumping against the side limited memory
another form of artificial intelligence
systems look into the past information
is added over a period of time
and information is short-lived when
we're talking about this
and you look at like a neural network
that's been programmed to identify
cars it doesn't remember all those
pictures
it has no memory as far as the hundreds
of pictures you process
through it all it has is this is the
pattern i use to identify
cars as the final output for that neural
network we looked at
so when they talk about limited memory
this is what they're talking about
they're talking about i've created this
based on all these things but i'm not
going to remember anyone specifically
theory of mind systems being able to
understand human emotions and how they
affect decision making to adjust their
behaviors
according to their human understanding
this is important because this is our
page mark this is how we know
whether it is an artificial intelligence
or not
is it interacting with humans in a way
that we can understand
without that interaction is just an
object so we talk about theory of mind
we really understand
how it interfaces that whole if you're
in web development user experience would
be the term i would put in there
so the theory of mind would be user
experience how is the whole ui
connected together and one of the final
things is as we get into artificial
intelligence
is systems being aware of themselves
understanding their internal states
and predicting other people's feelings
and act appropriately
so as artificial intelligence continues
to progress
we see ones are trying to understand
well what makes people happy
how would they increase our happiness
how would they keep themselves from
breaking down if something's broken
inside they have that self-awareness to
be able to fix it
and just based on all that information
predicting which action would work the
best what would help
people if i know that you're having a
cup of coffee first thing in the morning
is what makes you happy
as a robot i might make you a cup of
coffee every morning at the same time
to help your life and help you grow
that'd be the self-awareness is being
able to know all those different things
types of machine learning and like i
said on the last slide this is very
important this is very important if you
decide to go in and get certified in
machine learning or know more about it
these are the three primary types of
machine learning
the first one is supervised learning
systems are able to predict
future outcome based on past data
requires both an input and an output to
be given to the model for it to be
trained
so in this case we're looking at
anything where you have a hundred
images of a bicycle and those hundred
images
you know are bicycle so it's they're
presets someone already looked at all
hundred images and said these are
pictures of bicycles
and so the computer learns from those
and then it's given another picture
and maybe the next picture is a bicycle
and it says oh
that resembles all these other bicycles
so it's a bicycle and the next one's a
car and it says
that's not a bicycle that would be
supervised learning because we had to
train it we had to supervise it
unsupervised learning systems are able
to identify hidden patterns from the
input data provided
by making the data more readable and
organized the patterns
similarities or anomalies become more
evident you'll heard the term
cluster how do you cluster things
together some of these things go
together some of these don't this is
unsupervised where you can look at an
image
and start pulling the different pieces
of the image out
because they aren't the same the human
all the parts of the human are not the
same as a fuzzy tree behind them because
it's slightly out of focus
which is not the same as the beach ball
it's unsupervised because we never told
it what a beach ball was we never told
them what the human was and we never
told it that those were trees
all we told it was hey separate this
picture by things that
don't match and things that do match and
come together
and finally there's reinforcement
learning systems are given
no training it learns on the basis of
the reward punishment it received for
performing its last action
it helps increase the efficiency of a
tool function or a program
reinforced learning or reinforcement
learning
is kind of you give it a yes or no yes
you gave me the right response
no you didn't and then it looks at that
and says oh okay so based on this data
coming in
what i gave you was a wrong response so
next time i'll give you a different one
comparing machine learning and deep
learning so remember that deep learning
is a subcategory of machine learning so
it's one of the many tools
and so they were grouping a ton of
machine learning tools all together
linear regression k means clustering
there's all kinds of cool tools out
there you can use
in machine learning enables machines to
take decisions
to make decisions on their own based on
past data
enables machines to make decisions with
the help of artificial neural networks
so it's doing the same thing but we're
using an artificial neural network
as opposed to one of the more
traditional machine learning tools
needs only a small amount of training
data this is very important when you're
talking about machine learning
they're usually not talking about huge
amounts of data we're talking about
maybe your spreadsheet from your
business and your
totals for the end of the year when
you're talking about neural networks
you usually need a large amount of data
to train the data so there's a lot of
training involved if you have under 500
points of data
that's probably not going to go into
machine learning
or maybe you have like the case of one
of the things 500
points of data and 30 different fields
it starts getting really confusing there
in artificial intelligence or
machine learning and the deep learning
aspect really shines when you get to
that
larger data that's really complex works
well on a low end systems
so a lot of the machine learning tools
out there you can run on your laptop
with no problem and do the calculations
there
where with the machine learning usually
needs a higher end system to work it
takes a lot more processing power to
build those neural networks and
to train them it goes through a lot of
data we're talking about the general
machine learning tools
most features need to be identified in
advanced and manually coded
so there's a lot of human work on here
the machine learns the features from the
data
it has provided so again it's like a
magic box
you don't have to know what a tire is it
figures it out for you
the problem is divided into parts and
solved individually and then combined
so machine learning you usually have all
these different tools and use different
tools for different parts
and the problem is solved in an
end-to-end manner so you only have one
neural network or two neural networks
that is bringing the data in and putting
it out it's not going through
a lot of different processes to get
there and remember you can put machine
learning and deep learning together
so you don't always have just the deep
learning
solving the problem by having selling
one piece of the puzzle
with regular machine learning and most
machine learning tools out there
they take longer to test and understand
how they work
and with the deep learning it's pretty
quick once you build that neural network
you test it and you know
so we're dealing with very crisp rules
limited resources
you have to really explain how the
decision was made when you use most
machine learning tools
but when you use the deep learning tool
inside the machine learning tools
the system takes care of it based on its
own logic and reasoning
and again it's like a magic black box
you really don't know
how it came up with the answer you just
know it came up with the right answer
a glimpse into the future so a quick
glimpse into the future
artificial intelligence be using it to
detecting crimes before they happen
humanoid ai helpers which we already
have a lot of there'll be more and more
maybe it'll actually be androids that'd
be cool to have an android that comes
and get stuff out of my fridge for me
machine learning increasing efficiency
in healthcare that's really big
in all the forms of machine learning
better marketing techniques
any of these things if we get into the
sciences it's just off the scale
machine learning and artificial
intelligence go everywhere
and then the subcategory deep learning
increased personalization
so what's really nice about the deep
learning is it's going to start now
catering to you
that'll be one of the things we see more
and more of and we'll have more of a
hyper intelligent
personal assistant i'm excited about
that machine learning has improved our
lives in a number of wonderful ways
today let's talk about some of these i'm
rahul from simply learn and these are
the top 10 applications of machine
learning
first let's talk about virtual personal
assistants google assistant
alexa cortana and siri now we've all
used one of these at least at some point
in our lives now these help improve our
lives in a great number of ways
for example you could tell them to call
someone you could tell them to play some
music you could tell them to even
schedule an appointment
so how do these things actually work
first they record whatever you're saying
send it over to a server which is
usually in a cloud decode it with the
help of machine learning in neural
networks and then provide you with an
output
so if you ever notice that these systems
don't work very well without the
internet
that's because the server couldn't be
contacted next let's talk about traffic
predictions
now say i wanted to travel from
buckingham palace to large cricket
ground the first thing i would probably
do is to get on google maps
so search it
and let's put it here
so here we have the path you should take
to get to large cricket ground
now here the map is a combination of red
yellow and blue now the blue regions
signify a clear road that is you won't
encounter traffic there
the yellow indicate that they're
slightly congested and red means they're
heavily congested
so let's look at the map a different
version of the same map and here
as i told you before red means heavily
congested yellow means slow moving
and blue means clear so how exactly is
google
able to tell you that the traffic is
clear slow moving or heavily congested
so this is
the help of machine learning and with
the help of two important measures
first is the average time that's taken
on specific days at specific times on
that route the second one
is the real-time location data of
vehicles from google maps and with the
help of sensors
some of the other popular map services
are bing maps maps dot me
and here we go next up we have social
media personalization so say i want to
buy a drone and
i'm on amazon and i want to buy a dji
mavic pro the thing is it's close to one
lap so i don't want to buy it right now
but the next time i'm on facebook i'll
see an advertisement for the product
next time i'm on youtube i'll see an
advertisement even on instagram i'll see
an advertisement so here with the help
of machine learning
google has understood that i'm
interested in this particular product
hence it's targeting me with these
advertisements this is also with the
help of machine learning let's talk
about email spam filtering now this is a
spam that's in my inbox now how does
gmail know what spam
and what's not spam so gmail has an
entire collection of emails which have
already been labeled as spam or not spam
so after analyzing this data gmail is
able to find some characteristics like
the word lottery or winner
from then on any new email that comes to
your inbox goes through a few spam
filters to decide whether it's spam or
not
now some of the popular spam filters
that gmail uses is
content filters header filters general
blacklist filters and so on
next we have online fraud detection now
there are several ways that online fraud
can take place for example there's
identity theft where they steal your
identity
fake accounts where these accounts only
last for how long the transaction takes
place and stop existing after that
and man in the middle attacks where they
steal your money while the transaction
is taking place
the feed forward neural network helps
determine whether a transaction is
genuine or fraudulent so what happens
with feed forward neural networks are
that the outputs are converted into hash
values and these values become the
inputs for the next round so for every
real transaction that takes place
there's a specific pattern a fraudulent
transaction would stand out because of
the significant changes that it would
cause with the hash values stock market
trading
machine learning is used extensively
when it comes to stock market trading
now you have stock market indices like
nikai they use
long short-term memory neural networks
now these are used to classify
process and predict datum when there are
time lags of unknown size and duration
now this is used to predict stock market
trends assistive medical technology
now medical technology has been
innovated with the help of machine
learning diagnosing diseases has been
easier
from which we can create 3d models that
can predict where exactly there are
lesions in the brain it works just as
well for brain tumors and ischemic
stroke lesions they can also be used in
fetal imaging and cardiac analysis
now some of the medical fields that
machine learning will help assist in
is disease identification personalized
treatment drug
discovery clinical research and
radiology and finally we have automatic
translation
now say you're in a foreign country and
you see billboards and signs that you
don't understand that's where automatic
translation comes of help
now how does automatic translation
actually work the technology behind it
is the same as the sequence of sequence
learning which is the same thing that's
used with chat chatbots here the image
recognition happens using convolutional
neural networks and the text is
identified using optical character
recognition furthermore the sequential
sequence algorithm is also used to
translate the text from one language to
the other
there are many interesting machine
learning algorithms let's have a look at
a few of them
hopefully this gives you a little flavor
what's out there and these are some of
the most important ones that are
currently being used
we'll take a look at linear regression
decision tree
and the support vector machine let's
start with a closer look at
linear regression linear regression is
perhaps one of the most well-known and
well-understood algorithms in statistics
and machine learning
linear regression is a linear model for
example a model that assumes a linear
relationship between
the input variables x and the single
output variable
y and you'll see this if you remember
from your algebra classes
y equals mx plus c imagine we are
predicting distance traveled y
from speed x our linear regression model
representation for this problem
would be y equals m times x plus c or
distance equals m times speed plus c
where m is the coefficient and c is the
y-intercept
and we're going to look at two different
variations of this first we're going to
start with
time is constant and you can see we have
a bicyclist
he's got a safety gear on thank goodness
speed equals 10 meters per second
and so over a certain amount of time his
distance equals 36 kilometers
we have a second bicyclist he's going
twice the speed or
20 meters per second and you can guess
if he's going twice the speed and time
is a constant
then he's going to go twice the distance
and that's easy to compute 36 times 2
you get
72 kilometers and so if you had the
question of
how fast would somebody is going three
times at speed or 30 meters per second
is
you can easily compute the distance in
our head we can do that without needing
a computer but we want to do this for
more complicated data so it's kind of
nice to compare the two but let's just
take a look at that and what that looks
like in a graph
so in a linear regression model we have
our distance to the speed
and we have our m equals the ve slope
of the line and we'll notice that the
line has a plus slope
and as the speed increases distance also
increases hence the variables have a
positive relationship and so your speed
of the person which equals y equals mx
plus c
distance traveled in a fixed interval of
time and we could very easily compute
either following the line or just
knowing it's 3 times 10 meters per
second that this is roughly 102
kilometers distance that this third
bicep
has traveled one of the key definitions
on here is positive relationship
so the slope of the line is positive as
distance increase
so does speed increase let's take a look
at our second example where we put
distance is a constant so we have speed
equals 10 meters per second
they have a certain distance to go and
it takes him 100 seconds to travel that
distance
and we have our second bicyclist who's
still doing 20 meters per second
since he's going twice the speed we can
guess that he'll cover the distance in
about half the time
50 seconds and of course you could
probably guess on the third one
100 divided by 30 since he's going 3
times the speed
you can easily guess that this is 33.333
seconds time we put that into a linear
regression model or
graph if the distance is assumed to be
constant let's see the relationship
between speed and time
and as time goes up the amount of speed
to go that same distance
goes down so now your m equals a minus
ve slope of the line
as the speed increases time decreases
hence the variable
has a negative relationship again
there's our definition
positive relationship and negative
relationship depended on the slope of
the line
and with a simple formula like this
and even a significant amount of data
let's see with the mathematical
implementation of linear regression
and we'll take this data so suppose we
have this data set where we have x
y x equals 1 2 3 4 5
standard series and the y value is 3
2 2 4 3. when we take that and we go
ahead and
plot these points on a graph you can see
there's kind of a nice scattering
and you could probably eyeball a line
through the middle of it
but we're going to calculate that exact
line for linear regression
and the first thing we do is we come up
here we have the mean
of x i and remember mean is basically
the average
so we added five plus four plus three
plus two plus one and divide by five
and that simply comes out as 3 and then
we'll do the same for y
we'll go ahead and add up all those
numbers and divide by 5
and we end up with the mean value of y
of i equals
2.8 where the x i references it's an
average or means value and the y i also
equals a means value of y and when we
plot that you'll see that we can put in
the y equals 2.8 and the x equals 3
in there on our graph we kind of give it
a little different color so you could
sort it out with the dashed lines on it
and it's important to note that when we
do the linear regression the linear
regression model
should go through that dot now let's
find our regression equation to find the
best fit line
remember we go ahead and take our y
equals mx plus c so we're looking for
m and c so to find this equation for our
data
we need to find our slope of m and our
coefficient of
c and we have y equals mx
plus c where m equals the sum of
x minus x average times y minus y
average or y means and x means over the
sum of
x minus x means squared that's how we
get the slope of the value of the line
and we can easily do that by creating
some columns here we have x y
computers are really good about
iterating through data and so we can
easily
compute this and fill in a graph of data
and in our graph you can easily see that
if we have our x value of 1
and if you remember the x i or the means
value is 3 1 minus 3 equals
a negative 2 and 2 minus 3 equals
a negative 1 so on and so forth and we
can easily fill in the column of x minus
x i
y minus y i and then from those we can
compute
x minus x i squared and x minus x i
times y minus y i and you can guess it
that the next step is to go ahead and
sum the different columns for the
answers we need
so we get a total of 10 for our x minus
x i squared and a total of 2 for x minus
x i
times y minus y i and we plug those in
we get
2 10 which equals 0.2 so now we know the
slope of our line equals 0.2
so we can calculate the value of c
that'd be the next step is we need to
know where it crosses the y
axis and if you remember i mentioned
earlier
that the linear regression line has to
pass through
the means value the one that we showed
earlier we can just flip back up there
to that graph
and you can see right here there's our
means value which is 3
x equals 3 and y equals 2.8 and since we
know that value
we can simply plug that into our formula
y equals 0.2 x plus c so we plug that in
we get 2.8
equals 0.2 times 3 plus c and you can
just solve for c
so now we know that our coefficient
equals 2.2
and once we have all that we can go
ahead and plot our regression line
y equals 0.2 times x plus 2.2
and then from this equation we can
compute
new values so let's predict the values
of y using
x equals 1 2 3 4 5 and plot the points
remember the 1 2 3 4 5 was our original
x values
so now we're going to see what y thinks
they are not what they actually are
and we plug those in we get y of
designated with y of p
you can see that x equals 1 equals 2.4 x
equals 2 equals 2.6
and so on and so on so we have our y
predicted
values of what we think is going to be
when we plug those numbers in
and when we plot the predicted values
along with the actual values
we can see the difference and this is
one of the things that's very important
with linear aggression in any of these
models
is to understand the error and so we can
calculate the error on all of our
different values and you can see over
here we plotted
x and y and y predict and we draw a
little line so you can sort of see what
the error looks like there between the
different points
so our goal is to reduce this error we
want to minimize that error value
on our linear regression model
minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute
errors root mean square error etc
we keep moving this line through the
data points to make sure the best fit
line
has the least square distance between
the data points and the regression line
so to recap with a very simple linear
regression model
we first figure out the formula of our
line through the middle
and then we slowly adjust the line to
minimize the error
keep in mind this is a very simple
formula the math gets even though the
math is very much the same it gets much
more complex as we add in
different dimensions so this is only two
dimensions y equals
mx plus c but you can take that out to x
z i j q all the different features in
there and they can plot a linear
regression model on all of those
using the different formulas to minimize
the error
let's go ahead and take a look at
decision trees a very different way to
solve problems in the linear regression
model
decision tree is a tree-shaped algorithm
used to determine a course of action
each branch of a tree represents a
possible decision occurrence or reaction
we have data which tells us if it is a
good day to play golf
and if we were to open this data up in a
general spreadsheet
you can see we have the outlook whether
it's a rainy overcast sunny
temperature hot mild cool humidity
windy and did i like to play golf that
day yes or no
so we're taking a census and certainly i
wouldn't want a computer telling me when
i should go play golf or not
but you can imagine if you got up in the
night before you're trying to plan your
day
and it comes up and says tomorrow would
be a good day for golf for you
in the morning and not a good day in the
afternoon or something like that
this becomes very beneficial and we see
this in a lot of applications coming out
now where it gives you suggestions
and lets you know what would be fit the
match for you for the next day or the
next purchase
or the next whatever you know next mail
out in this case
is tomorrow a good day for playing golf
based on the weather coming in
and so we come up and let's uh determine
if you should play golf
when the day is sunny and windy so we
found out the forecast tomorrow is going
to be sunny and windy
and suppose we draw our tree like this
we're going to have our humidity
and then we have our normal which is if
it's if you have a normal humidity
you're going to go play golf
and if the humidity is really high then
we look at the outlook and if the
outlook is sunny overcast or rainy
it's going to change what you choose to
do so if you
know that it's a very high humidity and
it's sunny
you're probably not going to play golf
because you're going to be out there
miserable
fighting off the mosquitoes that are out
joining you to play golf with you
maybe if it's raining you probably don't
want to play in the rain but if it's
slightly overcast
you get just the right shadow that's a
good day to play golf and be outside out
on the green
now in this example you can probably
make your own tree
pretty easily because it's a very simple
set of data going in
but the question is how do you know what
to split where do you split your data
what if this is much more complicated
data
where it's not something that you would
particularly
understand like studying cancer they
take about 36 measurements of the
cancerous
cells and then each one of those
measurements represents
how bulbous it is how extended it is how
sharp the edges are
something that as a human we would have
no understanding of
so how do we decide how to split that
data up and is that the right decision
tree but
so it's a question it's going to come up
is this the right decision tree
for that we should calculate entropy and
information
gain two important vocabulary words
there are the entropy
and the information gain entropy entropy
is a measure of randomness or impurity
in the data set
entropy should be low so we want the
chaos to be as low as possible
we don't want to look at it and be
confused by the images or what's going
on there with mixed data
and the information gain it is a measure
of decrease in entropy
after the data set is split also known
as entropy
reduction information gain should be
high so we want our information that we
get out of the split to be as high as
possible
let's take a look at entropy from the
mathematical side
in this case we're going to denote
entropy as
i of p of and n where p
is the probability that you're going to
play a game of golf and
n is the probability where you're not
going to play the game of golf
now you don't really have to memorize
these formulas there's a few of them out
there depending on what you're working
with but it's important to note that
this is where this formula is coming
from
so when you see it you're not lost when
you're running your programming unless
you're building your own decision tree
code in the back and we simply have a
log squared of p
over p plus n minus n over p plus n
times the log squared of
n of p plus n but let's break that down
and see what
actually looks like when we're computing
that from the computer script side
entropy of a target class of the data
set is the whole entropy
so we have entropy play golf and we look
at this
if we go back to the data you can simply
count how many yeses and no
in our complete data set for playing
golf days
in our complete set we find we have five
days we did play golf
and nine days we did not play golf and
so our i
equals if you had those together 9 plus
5 is 14.
and so our i equals 5 over 14 and 9 over
14. that's our p and n values that we
plug into that formula
and you can go to 5 over 14 equals 0.36
9 over 14 equals 0.64 and when you do
the whole
equation you get the minus 0.36
log root squared of 0.36 minus 0.64
log squared root of 0.64 and we get a
set value we get
0.94 so we now have a full entropy value
for the whole set of data that we're
working with
and we want to make that entropy go down
and just like we calculated the entropy
out for the whole set
we can also calculate entropy for
playing golf and the outlook
is it going to be overcast or rainy or
sunny
and so we look at the entropy we have p
of sunny times e
of 3 of 2 and that just comes out how
many sunny days
yes and how many sunny days no over the
total which is five don't forget to put
the we'll divide that five out later on
equals p overcast equals four comma zero
plus rainy equals two comma three and
then when you do the whole
setup we have 5 over 14
remember i said there was a total of 5 5
over 14 times the i
of 3 of 2 plus 4 over 14 times the
4 comma 0 and 514 over i of 2
3. and so we can now compute the entropy
of just the part it has to do with the
forecast and we get 0.693
similarly we can calculate the entropy
of other predictors like temperature
humidity and wind and so we look at the
gain
outlook how much are we going to gain
from this entropy play golf minus
entropy play golf outlook
and we can take the original 0.94 for
the whole set
minus the entropy of just the rainy day
and temperature
and we end up with a gain of 0.247
so this is our information gain remember
we define entropy
and we define an information gain the
higher the information gain
the lower the entropy the better the
information gain of the other three
attributes can be calculated in the same
way
so we have our gain for temperature
equals 0.029
we have our gain for humidity equals
0.152
and our gain for a windy day equals
0.048
and if you do a quick comparison you'll
see the 0.247
is the greatest gain of information so
that's the split we want
now let's build the decision tree so we
have the outlook is it going to be sunny
overcast or rainy that's our first split
because that gives us the most
information gain
and we can continue to go down the tree
using the different information gains
with the largest information we can
continue down the nodes of the tree
where we choose the attribute with the
largest information gain as the root
node
and then continue to split each sub node
with the largest information gain that
we can compute
and although it's a little bit of a
tongue twister to say all that you can
see that's a very easy to view
visual model we have our outlook we
split it three different directions
if the outlook is overcast we're going
to play and then we can split those
further down if we want so if the
outlook is sunny but then it's also
windy
if it's windy we're not going to play if
it's not windy we'll play
so we can easily build a nice decision
tree to guess
what we would like to do tomorrow and
give us a nice recommendation for the
day
so we want to know if it's a good day to
play golf when it's sunny and windy
remember the original question that came
out tomorrow's weather report is sunny
and windy
you can see by going down the tree we go
outlook sunny outlook windy
we're not going to play golf tomorrow so
our little smart watch pops up and says
i'm sorry tomorrow's not a good day for
golf it's going to be
sunny and windy and if you're a huge
golf fan
you might go uh-oh it's not a good day
to play golf
we can go in and watch a golf game at
home so we'll sit in front of the tv
instead of being out playing golf in the
wind
now that we've looked at our decision
tree let's look at the third one of our
algorithms we're investigating
support vector machine support vector
machine is a widely used classification
algorithm
the idea of support vector machine is
simple the algorithm creates a
separation line which divides the
classes in the best possible manner
for example dog or cat disease or no
disease
suppose we have a labeled sample data
which tells height
and weight of males and females a new
data point arrives and we want to know
whether it's going to be a male
or a female so we start by drawing a
line
we draw decision lines but if we
consider decision line one
then we will classify the individual as
a male and if we consider decision line
two then it will be a female so you can
see this person kind of lies in the
middle of the two groups it's a little
confusing trying to figure out which
line they should be under
we need to know which line divides the
classes correctly
but how the goal is to choose a
hyperplane and that is one of the key
words they use when we talk about
support vector machines
choose a hyper plane with the greatest
possible margin between the decision
line
and the nearest point within the
training set so you can see here we have
our support vector we have the two
nearest points to it and we draw a line
between those two points
and the distance margin is the distance
between the hyperplane and the nearest
data point from either set so we
actually have a value
and it should be equal the distance
between the two
points that we're comparing it to when
we draw the hyperplanes we observe that
line one has a maximum distance
so we observe that line one has a
maximum distance margin so we'll
classify the new data point correctly
and our result on this one is going to
be that the new data point is mel
one of the reasons we call it a
hyperplane versus a line
is that a lot of times we're not looking
at just
weight and height we might be looking at
36
different features or dimensions and so
when we cut it with a hyperplane
it's more of a three-dimensional cut in
the data multi-dimensional
it cuts the data a certain way and each
plane continues to cut it down
until we get the best fit or match let's
understand this with the help of an
example
problem statement i always start with a
problem statement when you're going to
put some code together we're going to do
some coding now
classifying muffin and cupcake recipes
using support
vector machines so the cupcake versus
the muffin
let's have a look at our data set and we
have the different recipes here we have
a muffin recipe that has
so much flour i'm not sure what
measurement 55 is in but it has 55
maybe it's ounces but has a certain
amount of flour
certain amount of milk sugar butter egg
baking powder vanilla and salt
and so based on these measurements we
want to guess whether we're making a
muffin or a cupcake
and you can see in this one we don't
have just two features we don't just
have
height and weight as we did before
between the male and female in here
we have a number of features in fact in
this we're looking at eight
different features to guess whether it's
a muffin or a cupcake
what's the difference between a muffin
and a cupcake turns out muffins have
more flour
while cupcakes have more butter and
sugar so basically the cupcake's a
little bit more of a dessert
where the muffins a little bit more of a
fancy bread but how do we do that in
python how do we code that
to go through recipes and figure out
what the recipe is
and i really just want to say cupcakes
versus
muffins like some big professional
wrestling thing
before we start in our cupcakes versus
muffins we are going to be working
in python there's many versions of
python many different editors that is
one of the strengths
and weaknesses of python is it just has
so much stuff attached to it it's one of
the
more popular data science programming
packages you can use
in this case we're going to go ahead and
use anaconda
and jupiter nopa the anaconda navigator
has all kinds of fun
tools once you're into the anaconda
navigator you can change environments
i actually have a number of environments
on here we'll be using python36
environment
so this is in python version 3.6
although it doesn't matter too much
which version you use
i usually try to stay with the 3x
because they're current unless you have
a project that's very specifically in
version 2x
7 i think is usually what most people
use in the version 2.
and then once we're in our jupiter
notebook
editor i can go up and create a new file
and we'll just jump in here
in this case we're doing svm muffin
versus cupcake
and then let's start with our packages
for
data analysis and we almost always use
a couple there's a few very standard
packages we use
we use import import import
numpy that's for number python
they usually denote it as np that's very
comma
that's very common and then we're going
to import
pandas as pd and numpy
deals with number arrays there's a lot
of cool things you can do with the numpy
setup as far as multiplying all the
values
in an array in a numpy array data array
pandas
i can't remember if we're using it
actually in this data set i think we do
as an import
it makes a nice data frame and the
difference between a data frame
and a numpy array is that a data frame
is more like your excel spreadsheet
you have columns you have indexes you
have different ways of referencing it
easily viewing it and there's additional
features you can run on a data frame
and pandas kind of sits on numpy so you
need them both in there
and then finally we're working with the
support vector machine
so from sk learn we're going to use the
sk
learn model import svm
support vector machine
and then as a data scientist you should
always try to visualize
your data some data obviously is too
complicated or doesn't make any sense to
the human
but if it's possible it's good to take a
second look at it so you can actually
see what you're doing
now for that we're going to use two
packages we're going to import
matplotlibrary.piplot as plt
again very common and we're going to
import
seaborn as sns and we'll go ahead and
set the font scale
in the sns right in our import line
that's what this semicolon followed by
a line of data we're going to set the
sns and these are great because the
the seaborne sits on top of map plot
library just like pandas hits on numpy
so it adds a lot more features and uses
and control
we're obviously not going to get into
matplot library and seaborn that be its
own tutorial
we're really just focusing on the svm
the support vector machine from
sk learn and since we're in jupiter
notebook
we have to add a special line in here
for our
matplot library and that's your
percentage sign or
ambersign matplot library in line
now if you're doing this in just a
straight code project
a lot of times i use like notepad plus
plus and i'll run it from there
you don't have to have that line in
there because it'll just pop up as its
own window on your computer depending on
how your computer is set up
because we're running this in the
jupyter notebook
as a browser setup this tells it to
display
all of our graphics right below on the
page
so that's what that line is for remember
the first time i ran this i didn't know
that i had to go look that up
years ago it was quite a headache so
matplot library inline
is just because we're running this on
the web setup
and we can go ahead and run this make
sure all our modules are in they're all
imported which is great if you don't
have an import you'll need to go ahead
and pip
use the pip or however you do it there's
a lot of other
install packages out there although pip
is the most common
and you have to make sure these are all
installed on your python setup
the next step of course is we got to
look at the data you can't run
a model for predicting data if you don't
have actual data
so to do that let me go ahead and open
this up and take a look
and we have our cupcakes versus muffins
and it's a csv file or dot csv meaning
that it's comma separated variable
and it's going to open it up in a nice
spreadsheet for me
and you can see up here we have the type
we have muffin muffin muffin cupcake
cupcake cupcake
and then it's broken up into flour milk
sugar butter egg
baking powder vanilla and salt so we can
do is we can go ahead and look at this
data
also in our python
let us create a variable recipes equals
we're going to use our pandas module dot
read
csv remember is a comma separated
variable
and the file name happened to be
cupcakes versus
muffins oops i got double brackets there
do it this way
there we go cupcakes versus muffins
because the program i loaded or the the
place i saved this particular python
program is in the same folder
we get by with just the file name but
remember if you're storing it in a
different location you have to also put
down the full path on there
and then because we're in pandas we're
going to go ahead
and you can actually inline you can do
this but let me do the full print
you can just type in recipes dot head
in the jupiter notebook but if you're
running in code in a different script
you need to go ahead and type out the
whole print recipes dot head
and panda's nose is that's going to do
the first five
lines of data and if we flip back on
over to the spreadsheet where we opened
up our csv
file you can see where it starts on line
two
this one calls it zero and then two
three four five six is going to match
go and close that out because we don't
need that anymore and it always starts
at zero
and these are it automatically indexes
it since we didn't tell it to use an
index
in here so that's the index number for
the left hand side
and it automatically took the top row as
labels so pandas using it to read a csv
is just really slick and fast one of the
reasons we love our pandas
not just because they're cute and cuddly
teddy bears
and let's go ahead and plot our data
and i'm not going to plot all of it i'm
just going to plot the
sugar and flower now obviously
you can see where they get really
complicated if we have tons of different
features
and so you'll break them up and maybe
look at just two of them at a time to
see how they connect
and to plot them we're going to go ahead
and use seaborne
so that's our sns and the command for
that is sns.lm
plot and then the two different
variables i'm going to
plot is flour and sugar
data equals recipes the hue
equals type and this is a lot of fun
because it
knows that this is pandas coming in so
this is one of the
powerful things about pandas mixed with
seaborne in doing
graphing and then we're going to use a
palette set one
there's a lot of different sets in there
you can go look them up for seabourn
or do a regular fit regular equals false
so we're not really trying to fit
anything
and it's a scatter kws
a lot of these settings you can look up
in seabourn half of these you could
probably leave off when you run them
somebody played with this and found out
that these were the best settings
for doing a seaborn plot let's go ahead
and run that
and because it does it in line it just
puts it right on the page
and you can see right here that just
based on
sugar and flour alone there's a definite
split
and we use these models because you can
actually look at and say hey if i drew a
line
right between the middle of the blue
dots and the red dots
we'd be able to do an svm and a hyper
plane right there in the middle
then the next step is to format
or pre-process
our data and we're going to break that
up into two parts
we need a type label and remember
we're going to decide whether it's a
muffin or cupcake well a computer
doesn't know muffin or cupcake it knows
0
and 1. so what we're going to do is
we're going to create a type label
and from this we'll create a numpy array
and p where and this is where we can do
some logic
we take our recipes from our panda and
wherever
type equals muffin it's going to be zero
and then if it doesn't equal muffin
which is cupcakes is going to be
one so we create our type label this is
the answer
so when we're doing our training model
remember we have to have a training data
this is what we're going to train it
with is that it's zero or one it's a
muffin
or it's not and then we're going to
create our recipe
features and if you remember correctly
from right up here
the first column is type so we really
don't need the type columns that's our
muffin or cupcake
and in pandas we can easily sort that
out
we take our value recipes
dot columns that's a pandas
function built into pandas
we've got values converting them to
values so it's just the column titles
going across the top
and we don't want the first one so what
we do is it always starts at
zero we want one
colon till the end and then
we want to go ahead and make this a list
and this converts it to
a list of strings
and then we can go ahead and just take a
look and see we're looking at for the
features
make sure it looks right let me go ahead
and run that
and i forgot the s on recipes so we'll
go ahead and add the s
in there and then run that and we can
see we have flour milk sugar butter
egg baking powder vanilla and salt
and that matches what we have up here
right where we printed out
everything but the type so we have our
features and we have our label
now the recipe features is just the
titles of the columns and we actually
need
the ingredients
and at this point we have a couple
options one we could run it over all the
ingredients
and when you're doing this usually you
do but for our example we want to limit
it so you can easily see what's going on
because if we did all the ingredients
we have you know that's what
seven eight different hyperplanes that
would be built into it we only want to
look at once you can see what the svm is
doing
and so we'll take our recipes and we'll
do just flour
and sugar again you can replace that
with your recipe features and do all of
them but we're going to do just flour
and sugar
and we're going to convert that to
values we don't need to make a list out
of it because it's not string values
these are actual
values on there and we can go ahead and
just print
ingredients and you can see what that
looks like
and so we have just the amount of flour
and sugar just the two sets of plots
and just for fun let's go ahead and take
this over here
and take our recipe features
and so if we decided to use all the
recipe features
you'll see that it makes a nice column
of different data so it just strips out
all the labels and everything we just
have just the values
but because we want to be able to view
this easily in a
plot later on we'll go ahead and take
that and just do flower and
sugar and we'll run that you'll see it's
just the two columns
so the next step is to go ahead and fit
our model
we'll go ahead and just call it model
and it's a svm
we're using a package called svc
in this case we're going to go ahead and
set the kernel equals linear so it's
using a specific
set up on there and if we go to the
reference on their website
for the svm you'll see that there's
about there's eight of them here
three of them are for regression three
are for classification
the svc support vector classification is
probably one of the most commonly used
and then there's also one for detecting
outliers
and another one that has to do with
something a little bit more specific on
the model
but svc and sbr are the two most
commonly used
standing for support vector classifier
and support vector regression
remember regression is an actual value a
float value or
whatever you're trying to work on and
sbc is a classifier so it's a yes no
true false but for this we want to know
zero one
muffin cupcake if we go ahead and create
our model
and once we have our model created we're
gonna do model.fit
and this is very common especially in
the sk learn all their models
are followed with the fit command and
what we put into the fit what we're
training with it is we're putting in the
ingredients
which in this case we limited to just
flour and sugar
and the type label is it a muffin or
cupcake
now in more complicated data science
series
you'd want to split into we won't get
into that today we split it into
training data and test data and they
even do something where they split it
into thirds where a third is used for
whether you switch between which one's
training and test there's all kinds of
things
go into that it gets very complicated
when you get to the higher end
not overly complicated just an extra
step which we're not going to do today
because this is a very simple set of
data
and let's go ahead and run this and now
we have our model fit
and i got an error here so let me fix
that real quick
capital sbc it turns out
i did it lower case support vector
classifier there we go let's go ahead
and run that
and you'll see it comes up with all this
information that it prints out
automatically
these are the defaults of the model you
notice that we change the kernel to
linear
and there's our kernel linear on the
printout and there's other different
settings you can mess with we're going
to just leave that
alone for right now for this we don't
really need to mess with any of those
so next we're going to dig a little bit
into our
newly trained model and we're going to
do this so we can show you on a graph
let's go ahead and get the separating
and we're gonna say we're gonna use a w
for our variable on here
we're gonna do model dot coefficient
underscore
zero so what the heck is that again
we're digging into the model
so we've already got a prediction and a
train
this is a math behind it that we're
looking at right now
and so the w is going to represent
two different coefficients and if you
remember we had y
equals mx plus c so these coefficients
are connected to that
but in two dimensional it's a plane
we don't spend too much time on this
because you can get lost in the
confusion of the math
so if you're a math whiz this is great
you can go through here
and you'll see that we have a equals
minus w0
over w of one remember there's two
different values there
and that's basically the slope that
we're generating
and then we're going to build an xx what
is xx
we're going to set it up to a numpy
array there's our np
dot line space so we're creating a line
of values between 30 and 60. so it just
creates a set of numbers for x
and then if you remember correctly we
have our formula
y equals the slope times x
plus the intercept well to make this
work we can do this as
y y equals the slope
times each value in that array that's a
neat thing about numpy so when i do a
times
x x which is a whole numpy array of
values it multiplies a across
all of them and then it takes those same
values and we subtract
the model intercept that's here uh
where we had mx plus c so that'd be the
c from the formula
y equals mx plus c and that's where all
these numbers come from
a little bit confusing because it's
digging out of these different arrays
and then we want to do is we're going to
take this and we're going to go ahead
and plot it
so plot the parallels to separating
hyperplane
that pass through the support vectors
and so we're going to create
b equals a model support vectors
pulling our support vectors out there
here's our y y
which we now know is a set of data we
have we're going to create y y
down equals a times x x plus
b 1 minus a times b 0
and then model support vector b is going
to be set that to a new value the minus
1
set up and y y up equals a times
x x plus b 1 minus a times b
0. and we can go ahead and just run this
to load these variables up
if you wanted to understand a little bit
more of what's going on
you can see if we print
y y let me just run that you can see
it's an array this is a line it's going
to have
in this case between 30 and 60 so it's
going to be 30 variables in here
and the same thing with yy up yy
down and we'll we'll plot those in just
a minute on the graph so you can see
what those look like
just go ahead and delete that out of
here and run that so it loads up the
variables
nice clean slate i'm just going to copy
this from before
remember this our sns our seaborn plot
lm plot flower sugar
and i'll just go ahead and run that real
quick so you can see remember what that
looks like it's just a straight graph on
there
and then one of the neat things is
because seaborn sits on top of
pie plot we can do the pie plot for the
line going through
and that is simply plt.plot
and that's our x x and y y
are two corresponding values x y and
then somebody played with this to figure
out that the line width equals two
in the color black would look nice so
let's go ahead and run this whole thing
with the pie plot on there
and you can see when we do this it's
just doing flour and sugar on here
corresponding line between the sugar and
the flour and the
muffin versus cupcake
and then we generated the support
vectors the yy
down and yy up so let's take a look and
see what that looks like
so we'll do our pl plot and again this
is all against
x x our x value but this time we have y
y down
and let's do something a little fun with
this we can put in a
k dash dash that just tells it to
make it a dotted line and if we're going
to do
the down one we also want to do the up
one so here's our yy
up and when we run that it adds
both sets of line and so here's our
support and this is what you expect
you expect these two lines to go through
the nearest data point so the dashed
lines go through the nearest muffin
and the nearest cupcake when it's
plotting it and then your svm
goes right down the middle so it gives
it a nice split in our data
and you can see how easy it is to see
based just on sugar and flour
which one's a muffin or a cupcake
go ahead and create a function
to predict
muffin or cupcake
i've got my recipes i pulled off the
internet and i want to see the
difference between a
muffin or a cupcake and so we need a
function to push that through
and create a function with depth and
let's call it muffin or cupcake
remember we're just doing flour and
sugar today we're not doing all the
ingredients
and that actually is a pretty good split
you really don't need all the
ingredients to know it's flour and sugar
and let's go ahead and do an if else
statement so if
model predict
is a flower and sugar equals zero
so we take our model and we do it run a
predict it's very common in sk learn we
have a dot predict
you put the data in and it's going to
return a value
in this case if it equals zero then
print you're looking at a muffin recipe
else if it's not zero that means it's
one then you're looking at a cupcake
recipe
that's pretty straightforward for a
function
or def for definition def is how you do
that in python
and of course we're going to create a
function you should run something in it
and so let's run a
cupcake and we're going to send it
values 50 and 20 a muffin or cupcake i
don't know what it is
and let's run this and just see what it
gives us and it says oh it's a muffin
you're looking at a muffin recipe so it
very easily predicts whether we're
looking at a muffin or a cupcake
recipe let's plot this
there we go plot this on the graph so we
can see what that actually looks like
and i'm just going to copy and paste it
from below where we're plotting all the
points in there
so this is nothing different than we did
before if i run it
you'll see it has all the points and the
lines on there
and what we want to do is we want to add
another point
and we'll do plt plot
and if you remember correctly we did for
our test we did 50
and 20 and then somebody went in here
and decided we'll do
a y-o for yellow or it's kind of a
oranges yellow color is going to come
out
marker size nine those are settings you
can play with somebody else played with
them to
come up with the right setup so it looks
good and you can see there it is graphed
clearly a muffin in this case
in cupcakes versus muffins the muffin
has
won and if you'd like to do your own
muffin cupcake
contender series you certainly can send
a note down below
and the team at simply learn will send
you over the data they use for the
muffin and cupcake
and that's true of any of the data we
didn't actually run a plot on it earlier
we had men versus women
you can also request that information to
run it on your data setup so you can
test that out
so to go back over our setup we went
ahead for our support vector machine
code
we did a predict 40 parts flower 20
parts sugar
i think was different than the one we
did whether it's a muffin or a cupcake
hence we have built a classifier using
svm
which is able to classify if a recipe is
of a cupcake
or a muffin which wraps up our cupcake
versus muffin
what's in it for you we're going to
cover clustering
what is clustering k means clustering
which is one of the most common used
clustering tools out there
including a flow chart to understand
k-means clustering and how it functions
and then we'll do an actual python live
demo on clustering of cars based on
brands
then we're going to cover logistic
regression what is logistic regression
logistic regression curve and sigmoid
function
and then we'll do another python code
demo to classify a tumor as malignant or
benign
based on features and let's start with
clustering
suppose we have a pile of books of
different genres
now we divide them into different groups
like fiction
horror education and as we can see from
this young lady she definitely is into
heavy horror you can just
tell by those eyes and the maple
canadian leaf on her shirt
but we have fiction horror and education
we want to go ahead and divide our books
up
well organizing objects into groups
based on similarity is
clustering and in this case as we're
looking at the books we're talking about
clustering things with known
categories but you can also use it to
explore data so you might not know the
categories
you just know that you need to divide it
up in some way to conquer the data
and to organize it better but in this
case we're going to be looking at
clustering in specific categories
and let's just take a deeper look at
that we're going to use k
means clustering k means clustering is
probably the most commonly used
clustering tool
in the machine learning library k-means
clustering is an example of
unsupervised learning if you remember
from our previous thing
it is used when you have unlabeled data
so we don't know the answer yet we have
a bunch of data that we want to cluster
to different groups
define clusters in the data based on
feature similarity
so we've introduced a couple terms here
we've already talked about
unsupervised learning and unlabeled data
so we don't know the answer yet we're
just going to group stuff together and
see if we can find
an answer of how things connect we've
also
introduced feature similarity features
being different features of the data
now with books we can easily see fiction
and
horror and history books but a lot of
times with data
some of that information isn't so easy
to see right when we first look at it
and so k-means is one of those tools
where we can start finding things that
connect
that match with each other suppose we
have these data points and want to
assign them
into a cluster now when i look at these
data points i would probably group them
into two clusters just by looking at
them i'd say two of these group of data
kind of come together
but in k-means we pick k clusters and
assign random
centroids to clusters where the k
clusters represents two different
clusters
we pick k-clusters and cyrano centroids
to the clusters
then we compute distance from objects to
the centroids
now we form new clusters based on
minimum distances
and calculate the centroids so we figure
out what the best distance is for the
centroid then we move the centroid and
recalculate those distances
repeat previous two steps iteratively
till the cluster centroid stop changing
their positions and become
static repeat previous two steps
iteratively till the cluster centroid
stop changing and the positions become
static
once the clusters become static then k
means clustering algorithm is said to be
converged and there's another term we
see throughout machine learning is
converged
that means whatever math we're using to
figure out the answer
has come to a solution or it's converged
on an answer
shall we see the flowchart to understand
make a little bit more sense by putting
it into a nice easy step by step
so we start we choose k we'll look at
the elbow method in just a moment
we assign random centroids to clusters
and sometimes you pick the centroids
because you might look at the data in a
graph and say oh these are probably the
central points
then we compute the distance from the
objects to the centroids
we take that and we form new clusters
based on minimum distance and calculate
their centroids
then we compute the distance from
objects to the new centroids
and then we go back and repeat those
last two steps we calculate the
distances
so as we're doing it brings into the new
centroid
and then we move the centroid around and
we figure out what the best
which objects are closest to each
centroid so the objects can switch from
one centroid to the other the centroids
are moved around
and we continue that until it is
converged
let's see an example of this suppose we
have this data set of seven individuals
and their score on two topics
a and b so here's our subject
in this case referring to the person
taking the
test and then we have subject a where we
see what they've scored on their
first subject and we have subject b and
we can see what they score on the second
subject
now let's take two farthest apart points
as initials cluster centroids
remember we talked about selecting them
randomly or we can also just put them in
different points and pick the furthest
one apart so they move together
either one works okay depending on what
kind of data you're working on and what
you know about it
so we took the two furthest points one
and one
and five and seven and now let's take
the two farthest
apart points as initial cluster
centroids each point is then assigned to
the closest
cluster with respect to the distance
from the centroids
so we take each one of these points in
there we measure that distance and you
can see that
if we measure each of those distances
and you use it the
pythagorean theorem for a triangle in
this case because you know
the x and the y and you can figure out
the diagonal line from that
or you just take a ruler and put it on
your monitor that'd be kind of silly but
it would work
if you're just eyeballing it you can see
how they naturally come together in
certain areas
now we again calculate the centroids of
each cluster
so cluster one and then cluster two and
we look at
each individual dot there's one two
three we're in one
cluster the centroid then moves over it
becomes
1.8 comma 2.3 so remember was that one
and one
well the very center of the data we're
looking at would put it at the one point
roughly 2
2 but 1.8 and 2.3 and the second one
if we wanted to make the overall mean
vector the average vector of all the
different distances to that centroid
we come up with 4 comma 1 and 5 4. so
we've now moved the centroids
we compare each individual's distance to
its own cluster mean
and to that of the opposite cluster and
we find we can build a nice chart on
here
that the as we move the centroid around
we now have a new different kind of
clustering of groups
and using euclidean distance between the
points and the mean
we get the same formula you see these
new formulas coming up so we have our
individual dots
distance to the mean centroid of the
cluster and distance to the mean
centroid of the cluster
only individual three is nearer to the
mean of the opposite cluster
cluster two then its own cluster one and
you can see here in the diagram where
we've kind of
circled that one in the middle so when
we've moved the cluster
the centroids of the clusters over one
of the points shifted to the other
cluster
because it's closer to that group of
individuals thus
individual 3 is relocated to cluster 2
resulting in a new partition
and we regenerate all those numbers of
how close they are to the different
clusters
for the new clusters we will find the
actual cluster centroids so now we move
the
centroids over and you can see that
we've now formed two very distinct
clusters on here
on comparing the distance of each
individual's distance to its own cluster
mean
and to that of the opposite cluster we
find that the data points are stable
hence we have our final clusters
now if you remember i brought up a
concept earlier caming on the k-means
algorithm
choosing the right value of k will help
in less number of iterations
and to find the appropriate number of
clusters in a data set we use
the elbow method and within sum of
squares wss is defined as the sum of the
squared
distance between each member of the
cluster in its centroid
and so you see we've done here is we
have the number of clusters
and as you do the same k-means algorithm
over the different clusters
and you calculate what that centroid
looks like and you find the optimal you
can actually find the optimal number of
clusters using the elbow the graph
is called as the elbow method and on
this we guessed it two just by looking
at the data
but as you can see the slope you
actually just look for right there where
the elbow is in the slope and you have a
clear answer that we want
two different to start with k means
equals two a lot of times people end up
computing
k-means equals two three four five until
they find
the value which fits on the elbow joint
sometimes you can just look at the data
and if you're really good with that
specific domain
remember domain i mentioned that last
time you'll know that where to pick
those numbers or where to start guessing
at what that k value is
so let's take this and we're going to
use a use case
using k-means clustering to cluster cars
into brands
using parameters such as horsepower
cubic inches
make year etc so we're going to use the
dataset cars data
having information about three brands of
cars toyota
honda and nissan we'll go back to my
favorite tool
the anaconda navigator with the jupiter
notebook and let's go ahead and flip
over to our jupiter notebook
and in our jupiter notebook i'm going to
go ahead and just paste the
basic code that we usually start a lot
of these off with
we're not going to go too much into this
code because we've already discussed
numpy
we've already discussed matplot library
and pandas
that'll be being the number array pandas
being the pandas data frame
and map plot for the graphing and don't
forget since if you're using the jupiter
notebook you do need the matplot library
inline
so that it plots everything on the
screen if you're using a different
python editor then you probably don't
need that because it'll have a pop-up
window on your computer
now we'll go ahead and run this just to
load our libraries and our setup into
here
the next step is of course to look at
our data which i've already opened up
in a spreadsheet and you can see here we
have the miles per gallon
cylinders cubic inches horsepower weight
pounds
how heavy it is time it takes to get to
60
my card is probably on this one at about
80 or 90.
what year it is so this is you can
actually see this is kind of older cars
and then the brand toyota
honda nissan so the different cars are
coming from all the way from 1971 if we
scroll down
to the 80s we have between the 70s and
80s the number of cars that they've put
out and let's uh when we come back here
we're going to importing the data
so we'll go ahead and do data set equals
and we'll use pandas to read this
in and it's a from a csv file remember
you can always post this
in the comments and request the data
files for these
either in the comments here on the
youtube video or go to simplylearn.com
and request that
the car csv i put it in the same folder
as the code that i've stored so my
python code is stored in the same folder
so i don't have to put the full path
if you store them in different folders
you do have to change this and double
check your name variables
and we'll go ahead and run this and
we've chosen data set
arbitrarily because you know it's a data
set we're importing and we've now
imported our car csv
into the data set as you know you have
to prep the data so we're going to
create the x
data this is the one that we're going to
try to figure out what's going on with
and then there's a number of ways to do
this but we'll do it in a simple loop so
you can actually see what's going on so
we'll do four
i and x dot columns so we're going to go
through each of the columns
and a lot of times it's important i'll
make lists of the columns and do this
because i might remove certain columns
or there might be columns that
i want to be processed differently but
for this
we can go ahead and take x of i and we
want to go
fill in a and that's a pandas command
but the question is what are we going to
fill the
missing data with we definitely don't
want to just put in
a number that doesn't actually mean
something and so one of the tricks you
can do with this
is we can take x of i and in addition to
that we want to go ahead and turn this
into an integer because a lot of these
are integers so we'll go ahead and keep
it integers
and let me add the bracket here a lot of
editors will do this they'll think that
you're closing one bracket
make sure you get that second bracket in
there if it's a double bracket
that's always something that happens
regularly so once we have our integer of
x of y this is going to fill in
any missing data with the average and i
was so busy
closing one set of brackets i forgot
that the mean is also has brackets in
there
for the pandas so we can see here we're
going to fill in all the data with the
average value for that column so if
there's missing data it's in
the average of the data it does have
then once we've done that
we'll go ahead and loop through it again
and
just check and see to make sure
everything is filled in correctly
and we'll print and then we take x is
null and this returns a set of the null
value or the
how many lines are null and we'll just
sum that up to see what that looks like
and so when i run this
and so with the x what we want to do is
we want to remove the last column
because that had the models that's what
we're
trying to see if we can cluster these
things and figure out the models
there is so many different ways to sort
the x out
for one we could take the x and we could
go
data set our variable we're using and
use the i location
one of the features that's in pandas and
we could take that
and then take all the rows and all but
the last
column of the data set and at this time
we could do
values we just converted to values so
that's one way to do this and if i let
me just put this down here and print
x it's a capital x we chose and i run
this you can see it's just the values
we could also take out the values and
it's not going to return anything
because there's no values connected to
it what i like to do with this
is instead of doing the eye location
which does integers
more common is to come in here and we
have our data set
and we're going to do data set dot
or data set dot columns and remember
that lists all the columns
so if i come in here let me just
mark that as red and i print
data set dot columns
you can see that i have my index here i
have my mpg cylinders everything
including the brand which we don't want
so the way to get rid of the brand
would be to do data columns of
everything but the last
one minus one so now if i print this
you'll see the brand disappears
and so i can actually just take data set
columns
minus 1 and i'll put it right in here
for the columns we're going to look at
and let's un mark this and
unmark this
and now if i do an x dot head
i have a new data frame and you can see
right here we have
all the different columns except for the
brand at the end of the year
and it turns out when you start playing
with the data set
you're going to get an error later on
and it'll say cannot convert string
to float value and that's because if for
some reason these things the way they
recorded them must been recorded as
strings
so we have a neat feature in here on
pandas to convert
and it is simply convert objects
and for this we're going to convert oops
convert
underscore numeric
numeric equals true
and yes i did have to go look that up i
don't have it memorized the convert
numeric in there
if i'm working with a lot of these
things i remember them but
depending on where i'm at what i'm doing
i usually have to look it up
and we run that oops i must have missed
something in here let me double check my
spelling
and when i double check my spelling
you'll see i missed the first underscore
in the convert objects
when i run this it now has everything
converted
into a numeric value because that's what
we're going to be working with is
numeric values down here
and the next part is that we need to go
through the data
and eliminate null values most people
when they're doing small amounts
working with small data pools discover
afterwards that they have a null value
and they have to go back and do this
so you know be aware whenever we're
formatting this data
things are going to pop up and sometimes
you go backwards to fix it
and that's fine that's just part of
exploring the data and understanding
what you have
and i should have done this earlier but
let me go ahead and increase the size of
my window one notch
there we go easier to see
so we'll do 4i in working with x
dot columns we'll page through all the
columns
and we want to take x of i and we're
going to change that we're going to
alter it
and so with this we want to go ahead and
fill in
x of i pandas has the fill in
a and that just fills in any
non-existent missing data then we'll put
my brackets up and there's a lot of
different ways
to fill this data if you have a really
large data set some people just void out
that data because
and then look at it later in a separate
exploration of data one of the tricks we
can do
is we can take our column and we can
find the means
and the means is in other are quotation
marks
so we take the columns we're going to
fill in the non-existing one with the
means
the problem is that returns a decimal
float so
some of these aren't decimals certainly
let me be a little careful of doing this
but for this example we're just going to
fill it in
with the integer version of this keeps
it on par with the other data that isn't
a decimal point
and then what we also want to do is we
want to double check
a lot of times you do this first part
first to double check then you do the
fill and then you do it again just to
make sure you did it right
so we're going to go through and test
for
missing data and one of the ways you can
do that
is simply go in here and take our
x of i column so it's going to go
through the x of i column it says is
null
so it's going to return any any place
there's a null value it actually goes
through
all the rows of each column is null
and then we want to go ahead and sum
that so we take that and we add the sum
value and these
are all pandas so is null is a panda
command and so is sum
and if we go through that we go ahead
and run it
and we go ahead and take and run that
you'll see that all the columns
have zero null values so we've now
tested and double checked and our data
is nice and clean we have no
null values everything is now a number
value we turned it into numeric
and we've removed the last column in our
data
and at this point we're actually going
to start using the elbow method to find
the optimal number of clusters
so we're now actually getting into the
sk learn
part uh the k means clustering on here
i guess we'll go ahead and zoom it up
one more not so you can see what i'm
typing in here
and then from sk learn we're going to
our sk learn cluster
we're going to import k
means i always forget to capitalize the
k
and the m when i do this so it's capital
k capital m
k means and we'll go and create a
um array wcss equals let me get an empty
array
if you remember from the elbow method
from our slide
within the sums of squares wss is
defined as the sum
of square distance between each member
of the cluster and its centroid
so we're looking at that change in
differences as far as a square
distance and we're going to run this
over a number of k-mean values
in fact let's go for i in range we'll do
11 of them
rain zero of 11 and the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
create the actual
blue all lower case
and so we're going to create this object
from the k-means that we just imported
and the variable that we want to put
into this
is in clusters
we're going to set that equals to i
that's the most important one because
we're looking at how
increasing the number of clusters
changes our answer
there are a lot of settings to the
k-means
our guys in the back did a great job
just kind of playing with some of them
the most common ones that you see in a
lot of stuff is how you init your
k-means
so we have k-means plus plus
this is just a tool to let the model
itself be smart how it picks the
centroids to start with its initial
centroids we only want to iterate no
more than 300 times we have a max
iteration we put in there
we have the infinite the random state
equals zero
you really don't need to worry too much
about these when you're first learning
this
as you start digging in deeper you start
finding that these are shortcuts
that will speed up the process as far as
the setup but the big one that we're
working with is the in
clusters equals i so we're going to
literally
train our k means 11 times we're going
to do this process
11 times and if you're working with
big data you know the first thing you do
is you run a small sample of the data so
you can test all your stuff on it
and you can already see the problem that
if i'm going to iterate through a
terabyte of data
11 times and then the k-means itself is
iterating through the data multiple
times
that's a heck of a process so you got to
be a little careful with this a lot of
times though you can
find your elbow using the elbow method
find your optimal number on a sample of
data especially if you're working with
larger data sources so we want to go
ahead and take our k-means and we're
just going to fit it
if you're looking at any of the sklearn
very common
that you fit your model and if you
remember correctly our variable we're
using
is the capital x and once we fit this
value
we go back to the array we made and we
want to go and just depend that value on
the end and it's not the actual fit
we're pinning in there it's
when it generates it it generates the
value you're looking for is
inertia so k means dot inertia will pull
that specific value out
that we need and let's get a visual
on this we'll do our plt plot
and what we're plotting here is first
the x axis which is range 0 11 so that
will generate a nice little plot there
and the wcss for our y-axis
it's always nice to give our plot a
title
and let's see we'll just give it the
elbow method for the title
and let's get some labels so let's go
ahead and do plt
x label and we'll do number of clusters
for that
and plt y label
and for that we can do oops there we go
wcss
since that's what we're doing on the
plot on there and finally we want to go
ahead and display our graph
which is simply plt dot oops
dot show there we go and because we have
it set to inline
it'll appear in line hopefully i didn't
make a type error on there
and you can see we get a very nice graph
you can see a very nice elbow joint
there
at 2 and again right around 3
and 4 and then after that there's not
very much
now as a data scientist if i was looking
at this
i would do either three or four and i'd
actually try both of them to see what
the
output look like and they've already
tried this in the back so we're just
going to use three as a setup on here
and let's go ahead and see what that
looks like when we actually use this
to show the different kinds of cars
and so let's go ahead and apply the
k-means to the cars
data set and basically we're going to
copy the code that we loop through up
above
where k means equals k means number of
clusters and we're just going to set the
number of clusters to three
since that's what we're going to look
for and you could do three and four
on this and graph them just to see how
they come up differently be kind of
curious to look at that
but for this we're just going to set it
to 3. go ahead and create our own
variable
y k means for our answers
and we're going to set that equal to
whoops a double equal there
to k means but we're not going to do a
fit
we're going to do a fit predict is the
setup you want to use
and when you're using untrained models
you'll see
a slightly different because usually you
see fit and then you see just the
predict
but we want to both fit and predict the
k-means on this
and that's fit underscore predict and
then our capital x is the data we're
working with
and before we plot this data we're going
to do a little pandas trick
we're going to take our x value and
we're going to set x as
matrix so we're converting this into a
nice
rows and columns kind of set up but we
want the we're going to have columns
equals none
so it's just going to be a matrix of
data in here
and let's go ahead and run that
a little warning you'll see these
warnings pop up because things are
always being updated
so there's like minor changes in the
versions and future versions
instead of matrix now that it's more
common to set it dot
values instead of doing as matrix but
math matrix works just fine
for right now and you'll want to update
that later on but let's go ahead and
dive in and plot this and see what that
looks like
and before we dive into plotting this
data i always like to take a look and
see
what i am plotting so let's take a look
at y
k means i'm just going to print that out
down here
and we see we have an array of answers
we have 2 1
0 2 1 2. so it's clustering these
different rows of data based on the
three different
spaces it thinks it's going to be and
then let's go ahead and print
x and see what we have for x and we'll
see that x
is an array it's a matrix so we have our
different values in the array
and what we're going to do it's very
hard to plot all the different values in
the array
so we're only going to be looking at the
first two or positions zero and one
and if you were doing a full
presentation in front of the
board meeting you might actually do a
little different
than and dig a little deeper into the
different aspects because this is all
the different columns we looked at
but we look at columns one and two for
this to make it easy
so let's go ahead and clear this data
out of here and let's bring up
our plot and we're going to do a scatter
plot here so plt
scatter and
this looks a little complicated so let's
explain what's going on with this
we're going to take the x values
and we're only interested in y of k
means equals 0
the first cluster okay and then we're
going to take value
0 for the x axis and then we're going to
do the same thing here
we're only interested in k means equals
0 but we're going to take this second
column so we're looking at the first two
columns
in our answer or in the data and then
the guys in the back played with this a
little bit to make it pretty
and they discovered that it looks good
with as the size equals 100 that's the
size of the dots
we're going to use red for this one and
when they were looking at the data and
what came out
it was definitely the toyota on this
we're just going to go ahead and label
it toyota
again that's something you really have
to explore in here
as far as playing with those numbers and
see what looks good
we'll go ahead and hit enter in there
and i'm just going to paste in the next
two lines which is the next two cars
and this is our nissa and honda and
you'll see with our scatter plot we're
now looking at where
y underscore k means equals one and we
want the zero column and y k
means equals two again we're looking at
just the first two columns zero and one
and each of these rows then corresponds
to nissan and honda
and i'll go ahead and hit enter on there
and finally
let's take a look and put the centroids
on there again we're going to do a
scatter plot
and on the centroids you can just pull
that from our k-means
the model we created dot cluster centers
and we're going to just do
all of them in the first number and all
of them and the second number which is 0
1 because you always start with 0 and
one
and then they were playing with the size
and everything to make it look good
we'll do a size of 300 we're going to
make the color yellow
and we'll label them it's always good to
have some good labels centroids
and then we do want to do a title plt
title and pop up there
plt title cause you always want to make
your graphs look pretty and we'll call
it clusters of
car make and one of the features
of the plot library is you can add
a legend it'll automatically bring in
since we've already labeled the
different aspects of the legend with
toyota nissan and honda
and finally we want to go ahead and show
so we can actually see it and remember
it's inline
so if you're using a different editor
that's not the jupiter notebook
you'll get a pop-up of this and you
should have a nice set of clusters here
so we can look at this we have a
clusters of
honda and green toyota and red
nissan and purple and you can see where
they put the centroids to separate them
now when we're looking at this we can
also plot a lot of other
different data on here as far because we
only looked at the first two
columns this is just column one and two
or zero one as you
label them in computer scripting but you
can see here we have a nice clusters of
car make and we were able to pull out
the data
and you can see how just these two
columns form very distinct clusters of
data
so if you were exploring new data you
might take a look and say well what
makes these different
almost going in reverse you start
looking at the data and pulling apart
the columns to find out
why is the first group set up the way it
is
maybe you're doing loans and you want to
go well why is this group not defaulting
on their
loans and why is the last group
defaulting on their loans and why is the
middle group 50
defaulting on their bank loans and you
start
finding ways to manipulate the data and
pull out the answers you want
so now that you've seen how to use
k-mean
for clustering let's move on to the next
topic
now let's look into logistic regression
the logistic regression algorithm
is the simplest classification algorithm
used for binary or multi-classification
problems and we can see we have our
little girl from canada who's into
horror books is back
that's actually really scary when you
think about that with those big eyes
in the previous tutorial we learned
about linear regression
dependent and independent variables so
to brush up y equals mx plus c
very basic algebraic function of
y and x the dependent variable is the
target class variable we are going to
predict
the independent variables x1
all the way up to xn are the features or
attributes we are going to use to
predict the target class
we know what a linear regression looks
like but using the graph we cannot
divide the outcome into categories
it's really hard to categorize 1.5 3.6
9.8 for example a linear regression
graph can tell us
that with increase in number of hours
studied
the marks of a student will increase but
it will not tell us whether the student
will pass or not
in such cases where we need the output
as categorical value
we will use logistic regression and for
that we're going to use the sigmoid
function
so you can see here we have our marks 0
to 100
number of hours studied that's going to
be what they're comparing it to
in this example and we usually form a
line that says y equals
mx plus c and when we use the sigmoid
function
we have p equals 1 over 1 plus e to the
minus
y it generates a sigmoid curve
and so you can see right here when you
take the ln
which is the natural logarithm i always
thought it should be
nl not ln that's just the inverse of
e your e to the minus y and so we do
this we get
ln of p over 1 minus p equals m
times x plus c that's the sigmoid curve
function we're looking for
now we can zoom in on the function and
you'll see that the function
as it derives goes to 1 or to 0
depending on what your x value is and
the probability if it's greater than
0.5 the value is automatically rounded
off to
1 indicating that the student will pass
so if they're doing a certain amount of
studying
they will probably pass then you have a
threshold value
at the 0.5 it automatically puts that
right in the middle usually
and your probability if it's less than
0.5 the value rendered off to zero
indicating the student will fail
so if they're not studying very hard
they're probably going to fail
this of course is ignoring the outliers
or that one student is just a natural
genius and doesn't need any studying to
memorize everything
that's not me unfortunately i have to
study hard to learn new stuff
problem statement to classify whether a
tumor is malignant
or benign and this is actually one of my
favorite
data sets to play with because it has so
many features
and when you look at them you really are
hard to understand
you can't just look at them and know the
answer so it gives you a chance to kind
of dive into what data looks like when
you aren't able to understand the
specific domain
of the data but i also want you to
remind you that in the domain of
medicine
if i told you that my probability
was really good it classified things
that say 90
or 95 and i'm classifying whether you're
going to have a malignant or a b9 tumor
i'm guessing that you're going to go get
it tested anyways so you got to remember
the domain we're working with
so why would you want to do that if you
know you're just going to go get a
biopsy because
you know it's that serious this is like
an all or nothing
just referencing the domain it's
important it might help the doctor
know where to look just by understanding
what kind
of tumor it is so it might help them or
aid them and something they missed from
before
so let's go ahead and dive into the code
and i'll come back to the domain part of
it in just a minute
so use case and we're going to do our
normal imports here we're importing
numpy
pandas seaborn the matplot library and
we're going to do matplot library in
line since i'm going to switch over to
anaconda
so let's go ahead and flip over there
and get this started so i've opened up a
new window
in my anaconda jupiter notebook
and by the way jupiter notebook you
don't have to use anaconda for the
jupiter notebook
i just love the interface and all the
tools and anaconda brings
so we got our import numpy as in p for
our
numpy number array we have our pandas pd
we're gonna bring in seaborn to help us
with our graphs as sns
so many really nice tools in both
seaboard and matplot library
and we'll do our matplotlibrary.piplot
as plt
and then of course we want to let it
know to do it in line and let's go and
just run that so it's all set
and we're just going to call our data
data not creative today
equals pd and this happens to be in a
csv file so we'll use the pd.read
underscore
csv and i happened to name the file i
renamed it
data for p2.csv you can of course
write in the comments below the youtube
and request for the data set itself or
go to the simply learn website and we'll
be happy to supply that for you
and let's just um open up the data
before we go any further and let's just
see what it looks like in a spreadsheet
so when i pop it open in a local
spreadsheet this is just a csv
file comma separated variables we have
an id
so i guess they categorize this for
reference or what id which test was done
the diagnosis m for malignant b
for b9 so there's two different options
on there and that's what we're going to
try to predict is the m and b
and test it and then we have like the
radius mean
or average the texture average perimeter
mean
area mean smoothness i don't know about
you but unless
you're a doctor in the field most of
stuff i mean you can guess what concave
means just by the term concave but i
really wouldn't know what that means in
the measurements they're taking
so they have all kinds of stuff like how
smooth it is
the symmetry and these are all float
values we just page through them real
quick
and you'll see there's i believe 36 if i
remember correctly in this one
so there's a lot of different values
they take and all these measurements
they take when they go in there and they
take a look at
the different growth the tumorous growth
so
back in our data and i put this in the
same folder as a code
so i saved this code in that folder
obviously if you have it in a different
location you want to put the full path
in there
and we'll just do pandas
first five lines of data with the
data.head
and we run that we can see that we have
pretty much what we just looked at we
have an id we have a diagnosis
if we go all the way across you'll see
all the different columns coming across
displayed nicely for our data
and while we're exploring the data our
seaborn which we referenced as sns
makes it very easy to go in here and do
a joint plot
you'll notice that very similar to
because it is sitting on top of the
plot library so the joint plot does a
lot of work for us
and we're just going to look at the
first two columns that we're interested
in the radius mean and the texture mean
we'll just look at those two columns
and data equals data so that tells it
which two columns we're plotting
and that we're going to use the data
that we pulled in let's just run that
and it generates a really nice graph on
here and there's all kinds of cool
things on this graph to look at i mean
we have the texture mean and the radius
mean
obviously the axes you can also see
and one of the cool things on here is
you can also see the histogram
they show that for the radius mean
whereas the most commons radius mean
come up and where the most common
texture is
that's when we're looking at the tech
the on each growth its average texture
and on each radius its average radius on
there
it's a little confusing because we're
talking about the individual objects
average and then we can also look over
here and see the
the histogram showing us the median or
how common each measurement is and
that's only two columns so let's dig a
little deeper into
seabourn they also have a heat map and
if you're not familiar with heat maps a
heat map
just means it's in color that's all that
means heat map
i guess the original ones were plotting
heat density on something and so ever
since then it's just called a heat map
and we're going to take our data and get
our corresponding numbers to put that
into the heat map
and that's simply data dot c-o-r-r
for that that's a pandas expression
let's remember we're working in a pandas
data frame so that's one of the cool
tools in pandas
for our data and this is pull that
information into a heat map
and see what that looks like and you'll
see that we're now looking at
all the different features we have our
id we have our texture we have our area
our compactness concave points and if
you look down the middle
of this chart diagonal going from the
upper left to bottom right
it's all white that's because when you
compare
texture to texture they're identical so
they're 100 percent
or in this case a perfect one in their
correspondence
and you'll see that when you look at say
area or right below it it has almost a
black on there when you compare it to
texture
so these have almost no corresponding
data they don't really form a linear
graph or something that you can look at
and say how connected they are they're
very scattered data
this is really just a really nice graph
to get a quick look at your data
doesn't so much change what you do but
it changes
verifying so when you get an answer or
something like that or you start looking
at some of these individual
pieces you might go hey that doesn't
match according to
showing our heat map this should not
correlate with each other and if it is
you're going to have to start asking
well why what's going on what else is
coming in there but it does show some
really cool information on here
and we can see from the id there's no
real one
feature that just says if you go across
the top line
that lights up there's no one feature
that says hey if the area is a certain
size then it's going to be b9 or
malignant
it says there's some that sort of add up
and that's a big
hint in the data that we're trying to id
this whether it's malignant
or b9 that's a big hint to us as data
scientists to go okay
we can't solve this with any one feature
it's going to be something that includes
all the features or many of the
different features to come up with the
solution for it
and while we're exploring the data let's
explore one more
area and let's look at data dot is null
we want to check for null values in our
data
if you remember from earlier in this
tutorial
we did it a little differently where we
added stuff up and summed them up
you can actually with pandas do it
really quickly data dot is null
and summit and it's going to go across
all the columns so when i run
this you're going to see all the columns
come up with no
no data so we've just
just to re hash these last few steps
we've done a lot of exploration we have
looked at the first two columns
and seen how they plot with the seaborn
with a joint plot which shows both the
histogram
and the data plotted on the x y
coordinates
and obviously you can do that more in
detail
with different columns and see how they
plot together
and then we took and did the seabourn
heat map the sns
dot heat map of the data and you can see
right here where it did a nice job
showing us some bright spots where stuff
correlates with each other
and forms a very nice combination or
points of scattering points
and you can also see areas that don't
and then finally we went ahead and
checked the data is the data
null value do we have any missing data
in there
very important step because it'll crash
later on
if you forget to do this step it will
remind you when you get that nice error
code that says no values
okay so not a big deal if you miss it
but
it's no fun having to go back when
you're you're in a huge process
and you've missed this step and now
you're 10 steps later and you've got to
remember where you were pulling the data
in
so we need to go ahead and pull out our
x and our y
so we just put that down here and we'll
set the x equal to
and there's a lot of different options
here certainly we could do
x equals all the columns except for the
first two because if you remember the
first two is the id and the diagnosis
so that certainly would be an option but
we're going to do is we're actually
going to focus
on the worst the worst radius the worst
texture
parameter area smoothness compactness
and so on one of the reasons to start
dividing your data up
when you're looking at this information
is
sometimes the data will be the same data
coming in so if i have two measurements
coming into
my model it might overweigh them it
might overpower
the other measurements because it's
measure it's basically taking that
information in twice
that's a little bit past the scope of
this tutorial i want you to take away
from this though is that we are dividing
the data up into pieces
and our team in the back went ahead and
said hey let's just look at the worst
so i'm going to create a an array and
you'll see this array
radius worst texture worse perimeter
worst we've just taken the worst of the
worst and i'm just going to put that in
my
x so this x is still a pandas data frame
but it's just those columns and our y if
you remember correctly
is going to be oops hold on one second
it's not x it's
data there we go so x equals data and
then it's a list of the different
columns the worst of the worst
and if we're going to take that then we
have to have our answer for our y
for the stuff we know and if you
remember correctly we're just going to
be looking at
the diagnosis that's all we care about
is what is it diagnosed is it
b9 or malignant and since it's a single
column we can just do diagnosis
oh i forgot to put the brackets or the
there we go okay
so it's just diagnosis on there and we
can also
real quickly do like x dot head if you
want to see what that looks like
and y dot head and run this
and you'll see it only does the last one
i forgot about that if you don't do
print
you can see that the the y dot head is
just mmm because the first ones are all
malignant
and if i run this the x dot head is just
the first
five values of radius worst texture
worse parameter worst area worst and so
on
i'll go ahead and take that out so
moving down
to the next step we've built our two
data sets our answer and then the
features we want to look at
in data science it's very important to
test
your model so we do that by splitting
the data
and from sklearn model selection we're
going to import
train test split so we're going to split
it into two groups
there are so many ways to do this i
noticed in one of the more modern ways
they actually split it into three groups
and then you model each group and test
it against the other groups
so you have all kinds and there's
reasons for that which is pass the scope
of this
and for this particular example isn't
necessary for this we're just going to
split it into two groups
one to train our data and one to test
our data and the
sklearn dot model selection we have
train test split
you could write your own quick code to
do this we just randomly divide the data
up into two groups
but they do it for us nicely and we
actually can almost we can actually do
it in one statement with this
where we're going to generate four
variables capital x
train capital x test so we have our
training data we're going to
use to fit the model and then we need
something to test it and then we have
our y train so we're going to train the
answer and then we have our test
so this is the stuff we want to see how
good it did on our model
and we'll go ahead and take our train
test split that we just imported
and we're going to do x and our y are
two different
data that's going in for our split and
then the guys in the back
came up and wanted us to go ahead and
use a test size equals
0.3 that's test underscore size
random state it's always nice to kind of
switch the random state around but not
that important
what this means is that the test size is
we're going to take 30 percent of the
data
and we're going to put that into our
test variables our y
test and our x test and we're going to
do 70
into the x train and the y train so
we're going to use 70
of the data to train our model and 30 to
test it
let's go ahead and run that and load
those up so
now we have all our stuff split up and
all our data ready to go
and now we get to the actual logistics
part we're actually going to do
our create our model so let's go ahead
and bring that in
from sklearn we're going to bring in our
linear model and we're going to
import logistic regression that's the
actual model we're using
and this we'll call it log model
stereo model and let's just set this
equal to
our logistic regression that we just
imported
so now we have a variable log model set
to that class for us to use
and with most the models in
the sk learn we just need to go ahead
and fix it
fit do a fit on there and we use our x
train that we separated out with our y
train and let's go ahead and run this so
once we've run this we'll have a model
that fits this data
that 70 percent of our training data
and of course it prints this out that
tells us all the different variables
that you can set on there there's a lot
of different choices you can make
but for word though we're just going to
let all the defaults sit we don't really
need to mess with those on this
particular example
there's nothing in here that really
stands out as super important
until you start fine tuning it but for
what we're doing the basics will work
just fine
and then let's we need to go ahead and
test out our model
is it working so let's create a variable
y predict
and this is going to be equal to our log
model and we want to do a predict again
very
standard format for the sklearn library
is taking your model and doing a predict
on it
and we're going to test why predict
against the y test
so we want to know what the model thinks
it's going to be that's what our y
predict is
and with that we want the capital x x
test so we have our train set and our
test set
and now we're going to do our y predict
and let's go ahead and run that
and if we uh print
y predict let me go ahead and run that
you'll see it comes up and it presents
and i prints a nice array of uh
b and m for b9 and malignant
for all the different test data we put
in there
so that's pretty good we're not sure
exactly how good it does but we can see
that it actually works and is functional
was very easy to create you'll always
discover with our data science
that as you explore this you spend a
significant amount of time
prepping your data and making sure your
data coming in is good
there's a saying good data in good
answers out
bad data in bad answers out that's only
half the thing that's only half of it
selecting your models becomes the next
part as far as how good your models are
and then of course fine-tuning it
depending on what model you're using
so we come in here we want to know how
good this came out so we have our y
predict here
log model dot predict x test
so for deciding how good our model is
we're going to go from the sklearn we're
going to import classification report
and that just reports how good our model
is doing and then we're going to feed it
the
model data let's just print this out and
we'll take our
classification report
we're going to put into there
our test our actual data so this is what
we actually know is true
and our prediction what our model
predicted for that data on the test side
and let's run that and see what that
does
so we pull that up you'll see that we
have a precision for
b9 and malignant b and m and we have a
precision of 93
91 a total of 92 so it's kind of the
average between these two 92 there's all
kinds of different information on here
your f1 score your recall your support
coming through on this and for this i'll
go ahead and just flip back to our
slides that they put together for
describing it
and so here we're going to look at the
precision using the classification
report
and you see this is the same printout i
had up above some of the numbers might
be different because it does randomly
pick out which data we're using
so this model is able to predict the
type of tumor
with 91 percent accuracy
so we look back here let's you'll see
where we have b9 and
it actually is 92 coming up here but
we're looking about a 92
91 precision and remember i reminded you
about domains and we're talking about
the domain of a medical domain
with a very catastrophic outcome you
know at 91 or 92 percent precision
you're still going to go in there and
have somebody do a biopsy on it
very different than if you're investing
money and there's a 92 percent chance
you're going to earn 10 percent
and 8 chance you're going to lose 8
you're probably going to bet the money
because at that odds it's pretty good
that you'll make some money and in the
long run
you do that enough you definitely will
make money and also with this domain
i've actually seen them use this to
identify different forms of cancer
that's one of the things that they're
starting to use these models for because
then it helps the doctor know what to
investigate
so that wraps up this section today
we're going to be looking at random
forest
one of the many powerful tools in the
machine learning library
before we dive into the topic let's
start by looking at a few of the uses
for
random forest currently today is used in
remote sensing
for example they're used in the etm
devices
if you're a space buff that's the
enhanced thermatic
mapper they use on satellites which see
far outside the human spectrum for
looking at land masses
and they acquire images of the earth's
surface the accuracy is higher
and training time is less than many
other machine learning tools out there
also object detection multi-class object
detection is done using random forest
algorithms
a good example is a traffic where you're
trying to sort out the different cars
buses and things
and it provides a better detection in
complicated environments they're very
complicated up there
and then we have uh another example
connect
and let's take a little closer look at
connect connect they use a random forest
as part of the game console and what it
does is it tracks the body movements and
it recreates it in the game
let's see what that looks like we have a
user who performs a step
in this case it looks like elvis presley
going there
that is then recorded so the connect
registers the movement
and then it marks the user based on
accuracy
and it looks like we have prints going
on this one
from elvis press leader prince that's
great uh so mark's user based on the
accuracy
if we look at that a little closer we
have a training set to identify
body parts where are the hands where the
feet
what's going on with the body that then
goes into a random forest classifier
that learns from it
once we've trained the classifier and
then identifies the body parts
while the person's dancing it's able to
represent that
in a computer format and then based on
that it scores the game
and how accurate you are as being elvis
presley or prince and you're dancing
so why random forest it's always
important to understand
why we use this tool over the other ones
what are the benefits here
and so with the random forest the first
one is there's no overfitting
if you use of multiple trees reduce the
risk of overfitting
training time is less overfitting means
that we have fit the data so close to
what we have as our sample
that we pick up on all the weird parts
and instead of predicting the overall
data you're predicting the weird stuff
which you don't want
high accuracy runs efficiently in large
database
for large data it produces highly
accurate predictions
in today's world of big data this is
really important
and this is probably where it really
shines this is where why random force
really comes in
it estimates missing data data in
today's world is very messy
so when you have a random forest it can
maintain the accuracy when a large
proportion of the data is missing
what that means is if you have data that
comes in from five or six
different areas and maybe they took one
set of statistics in one area
and they took a slightly different set
of statistics in the other so they have
some of the same
same shared data but one is missing like
the
number of children in the house if
you're doing something over demographics
and the other one is missing the size of
the house
it will look at both of those separately
and build two different trees
and then it can do a very good job of
guessing
which one fits better even though it's
missing that data let us dig
deep into the theory of exactly how it
works
and let's look at what is a random
forest
random forest or random decision forest
is a method that operates by
constructing multiple decision trees
the decision of the majority of the
trees is chosen by the random forest as
a final decision
and this uh we have some nice graphics
here we have a decision tree
and they actually use a real tree to
denote the decision tree which i love
and given a random some kind of picture
of a fruit
this decision tree decides that the
output is it's an apple and we have a
decision tree two
where we have that picture of the fruit
goes in and this one decides that it's a
lemon
and the decision three tree gets another
image and it decides it's an apple and
then this all comes together in what
they call the random forest
and this random forest then looks at it
and says okay i got two votes for apple
one vote for lemon the majority is
apples so the final decision is
apples to understand how the random
forest works
we first need to dig a little deeper and
take a look at the random forest and the
actual decision tree and how it builds
that decision tree
in looking closer at how the individual
decision trees work
we'll go ahead and continue to use the
fruit example since we're talking about
trees and forests
a decision tree is a tree shaped diagram
used to determine a course of action
each branch of the tree represents a
possible decision occurrence or reaction
so in here we have a bowl of fruit and
if you look at that it looks like
they switch from lemons to oranges we
have oranges cherries and
apples and the first decision of the
decision tree might be is a diameter
greater than or equal to three and if it
says false
it knows that they're cherries because
everything else is bigger than that so
all the cherries fall into that decision
so we have all that data we're training
we can look at that we know that that's
what's going to come up
is the color orange well goes hmm orange
or red
well if it's true then it comes out as
the orange
and if it's false that leaves apples so
in this example it
sorts out the fruit in the bowl or the
images of the fruit
a decision tree these are very important
terms to know because these are very
central to understanding the decision
tree and when working with them
the first is entropy everything on the
decision tree
and how it makes this decision is based
on entropy
entropy is a measure of randomness or
unpredictability in the data set
then they also have information gain the
leaf node
the decision node and the root node
we'll cover these other four terms as we
go down the tree
but let's start with entropy so starting
with
entropy we have here a high amount of
randomness
what that means is that whatever is
coming out of this decision
if it was going to guess based on this
data
it wouldn't be able to tell you whether
it's a lemon or an apple
it would just say it's a fruit so the
first thing we want to do is we want to
split this apart
and we take the initial data set we're
going to sit create a data set 1
and a data set 2. we just split it in
two and if you look at these new
data sets after splitting them the
entropy of each of those sets is
much less so for the first one whatever
comes in there it's going to sort that
data and it's going to say okay if this
data goes this direction
it's probably an apple and if it goes
into the other direction
it's probably a lemon so that brings us
up to information gain
it is the measure of decrease in the
entropy after the data set is split
what that means in here is that we've
gone from one set
which has a very high entropy to two
lower sets of entropy
and we've added in the values of e1 for
the first one
and e2 for the second two which are much
lower and so that information gain
is increased greatly in this example and
so you can find that the information
grain
simply equals decision e1
minus e2 as we're going down our list of
definitions we'll look at the leaf node
and the leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision
so we look down here to the leaf node we
finally get to
our set one or our set two when it comes
down there and it says
okay this object's gone into set one if
it's gone into set one
it's going to be split by some means and
will either end up with apples
on the leaf node or a lemon on the leaf
node and on the right it'll either be an
apple
or lemons those leaf nodes are those
final decisions or classifications
that's the definition of leaf node in
here if we're going to have a final leaf
where we
make the decision we should have a name
for the nodes above it
and they call those decision nodes a
decision node
decision node has two or more branches
and you can see here where we have the
five apples and one lemon and in the
other case the five lemons in one apple
they have to make a choice of which tree
it goes down
based on some kind of measurement or
information given to the tree
and that brings us to our last
definition the root node
the top most decision node is known as
the root node
and this is where you have all of your
data and you have your first decision it
has to make or the first split in
information
so far we've looked at a very general
image
with the fruit being split let's look
and see exactly what that means to split
the data
and how do we make those decisions on
there
let's go in there and find out how does
a decision tree work
so let's try to understand this and
let's use a simple example
and we'll stay with the fruit we have a
bowl of fruit
and so let's create a problem statement
and the problem is we want to classify
the different types of fruits in the
bowl based on different features
the data set in the bowl is looking
quite messy and the entropy is high
in this case so if this ball was our
decision maker it wouldn't know what
choice to make it has so many choices
which one do you pick apple
grapes or lemons and so we look in here
we're going to start with the dra
a training set so this is our data that
we're training our data with
and we have a number of options here we
have the color and under the color we
have red yellow purple
we have a diameter three three one three
three one
and we have a label apple lemon grapes
apple lemon grapes
and how do we split the data we have to
frame the conditions to split the data
in such a way that the information gain
is the
highest it's very key to note that we're
looking for the best gain
we don't want to just start sorting out
the smallest piece in there
we want to split it the biggest way we
can and so we measure this
decrease in entropy that's what they
call it entropy there's our entropy
after splitting and now we'll try to
choose a condition that gives us the
highest
gain we will do that by splitting the
data using each condition
and checking the gain that we get out of
them the conditions that give us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split
so let's take a look at these different
conditions we have color we have
diameter
and if we look underneath that we have a
couple different values we have diameter
equals three
color equals yellow red diameter equals
one
and when we look at that you'll see over
here we have
one two three four threes that's a
pretty high selection
so let's say the condition gives us a
maximum gain
of three so we have the most pieces fall
into
that range so our first split
from our decision node is we split the
data based on the diameter is it greater
than
or equal to three if it's not that's
false
it goes into the grape bowl and if it's
true it goes into a bowl fold of lemon
and apples
the entropy after splitting has
decreased considerably
so now we can make two decisions if you
look at there very much
less chaos going on there this node has
already attained an entropy value of 0
as you can see there's only one kind of
label left
for this branch so no further splitting
is required for this node
however this node on the right is still
requires a split to decrease the entropy
further
so we split the right node further based
on color
if you look at this if i split it on
color that pretty much
cuts it right down the middle it's the
only thing we have left in our choices
of color and diameter too
and if the color is yellow it's going to
go to the right bowl
and if it's false it's going to go to
the left bowl so the entropy in this
case is now
zero so now we have three bowls with
zero entropy there's only one type of
data in each one of those bowls
so we can predict a lemon with a hundred
percent accuracy
and we can predict the apple also with
100 accuracy
along with our grapes up there so we've
looked at kind of a basic
tree in our forest but what we really
want to know is
how does a random forest work as a whole
so to begin
our random forest classifier
let's say we already have built three
trees
and we're going to start with the first
tree that looks like this just like we
did in the example this tree looks at
the diameter if it's greater than or
equal to three
it's true otherwise it's false so one
side goes to the smaller diameter one
side goes to larger
diameter and if the color is orange
it's going to go to the right true we're
using oranges now instead of lemons
and if it's red it's going to go to the
left false we build a second tree very
similar
but split differently instead of the
first one being split by a diameter
uh this one when they created it if you
look at that first bowl
it has a lot of red objects so it says
is the color
red because that's going to bring our
entropy down the fastest
and so of course if it's true it goes to
the left if it's false it goes to the
right
and then it looks at the shape false or
true and so on and so on
and tree three is a diameter equal to
one
and it came up with this because there's
a lot of cherries in this bowl
so that would be the biggest split on
there is is the diameter equal to one
that's going to drop the entropy the
quickest
and as you can see it splits it into
true if it goes false and they've added
another category
does it grow in the summer and if it's
false it goes off to the left if it's
true it goes off to the right
let's go ahead and bring these three
trees you can see them all in one image
so this would be three completely
different trees categorizing a fruit
and let's take a fruit now let's try
this
and this fruit if you look at it we've
blackened it out you can't see the color
on it so it's missing data remember one
of the things we talked about earlier
is that a random forest works really
good if you're missing data
if you're missing pieces so this fruit
has an image but maybe the person had a
black and white
camera when they took the picture and
we're going to take a look at this
and it's going to have they put the
color in there so ignore the color down
there
but the diameter equals 3 we find out it
grows in the summer equals yes
and the shape is a circle and if you go
to the right you can look at what one of
the decision trees did
this is the third one is the diameter
greater than equal to three
is the color orange well it doesn't
really know on this one but if you look
at the value it'd say true and you go to
the right
tree two classifies it as cherries is a
color equal
red is the shape a circle true it is a
circle
so this would look at it and say oh
that's a cherry and then we go to the
other classifier and it says is the
diameter equal
one well that's false does it grow in
the summer
true so it goes down and looks at as
oranges so how does this random forest
work the first one says
it's an orange the second one said it
was a cherry
and the third one says it's an orange
and you can guess
if you have two oranges and one says
it's a cherry when you add that all
together
the majority of the vote says orange so
the answer is
it's classified as an orange even though
we didn't know the color and we're
missing data on it
i don't know about you but i'm getting
tired of fruit so let's switch
and i did promise you we'd start looking
at a case example and get into some
python
coding today we're going to use the case
the iris flower
analysis this is the exciting part as we
roll up our sleeves
and actually look at some python coding
before we start the python coding we
need to go ahead and create a problem
statement
wonder what species of iris do these
flowers belong to
let's try to predict the species of the
flowers using machine learning in
python let's see how it can be done so
here we begin to go ahead and implement
our python code and you'll find that the
first half of our implementation is all
about
organizing and exploring the data coming
in let's go ahead and take
this first step which is loading the
different modules into python and let's
go ahead and put that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case i'm going to be
using the anaconda jupiter notebook
which is one of my favorites certainly
there's notepad plus plus
and eclipse and dozens of others or just
even using the python
terminal window any of those will work
just fine to go ahead and explore
this python coding so here we go let's
go ahead and flip over to our jupyter
notebook
and i've already opened up a new page
for python 3 code
and i'm just going to paste this right
in there and let's take a look and see
what we're bringing into
our python the first thing we're going
to do is from the sklearn.datasets
import load iris now this isn't the
actual data this is just the module
that allows us to bring in the data the
load iris
and the iris is so popular it's been
around since 1936 when ronald fisher
published a paper on it and they're
measuring the different parts of the
flower
and based on those measurements
predicting what kind of flower it is
and then if we're going to do a random
forest classifier we need to go ahead
and import a random forest classifier
from the sk learn module
so sklearn.ensemble import random fourth
classifier
and then we want to bring in two more
modules and these are
probably the most commonly used modules
in python and data science
with any of the other modules that we
bring in
and one is going to be pandas we're
going to import pandas as pd
pd is a common term used for pandas and
pandas is basically
creates a data format for us where
when you create a pandas data frame it
looks like
an excel spreadsheet and you'll see that
in a minute when we start digging deeper
into the code
panda is just wonderful because it plays
nice with all the other modules in there
and then we have numpy which is
our numbers python and the numbers
python
allows us to do different mathematical
sets on here
we'll see right off the bat we're going
to take our np
and we're going to go ahead and seed the
randomness with it with 0. so
np.random.seed
is seating that is 0. this code doesn't
actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because i need to make sure i have all
those loaded and then let's take a look
at the next module on here
the next six slides including this one
are all about exploring the data
remember i told you half of this is
about
looking at the data and getting it all
set so let's go ahead and take
this code right here the script and
let's get that over into our jupyter
notebook
and here we go we've gone ahead and run
the
imports and i'm going to paste the code
down here
and let's take a look and see what's
going on the first thing we're doing is
we're actually loading
the iris data and if you remember up
here
we loaded the module that tells it how
to get the iris data
now we're actually assigning that data
to the variable iris
and then we're going to go ahead and use
the df to define
data frame and that's going to equal pd
and if you remember that's pandas as
pd so that's our pandas and panda data
frame and then we're looking at iris
data and columns equals iris feature
names
and we're going to do the df head and
let's run this you can understand what's
going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our df has created
what looks like an excel spreadsheet and
in this excel spreadsheet we have set
the columns
so up on the top you can see the four
different columns
and then we have the data iris.data down
below it's a little confusing without
knowing where this data is coming from
so let's look at
the bigger picture and i'm going to go
print i'm just going to change this for
a moment
and we're going to print all of iris and
see what that looks like
so when i print all of iris i get this
long list of information
and you can scroll through here and see
all the different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary
and in a python dictionary you'll have a
key or a label and this label pulls up
whatever information comes after it
so feature names which we actually used
over here under columns
is equal to an array of sepal length
sepal width petal length
petal width these are the different
names they have for the four different
columns
and if you scroll down far enough you'll
also see data down here oh goodness it
came up right towards the top
and data is equal to the different data
we're looking at
now there's a lot of other things in
here like target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute and there's
also the names
the target names which is further down
and we'll show you that also in a minute
let's go ahead and set that back to the
head
and this is one of the neat features of
pandas and panda data frames
is when you do df.head or the
pandadataframe.head
it'll print the first five lines of the
dataset in there along with the headers
if you have it in this case we have the
column header set to iris features
and in here you'll see that we have zero
one two
three four in python most arrays always
start at zero so when you look at the
first
five it's going to be zero one two three
four not one two three four five
so now we've got our iris data imported
into a data frame
let's take a look at the next piece of
code in here and so in this section here
of the code we're going to take a look
at the target
and let's go ahead and get this into our
notebook this piece of code so we can
discuss it a little bit more in detail
so
here we are in our jupiter notebook i'm
going to put the code in here
and before i run it i want to look at a
couple things going on so we have
df species and this is interesting
because right here you'll see where i
have df species
in brackets which is uh the key code for
creating another column
and here we have iris.target now these
are both in the
pandas setup on here so in pandas we can
do
either one i could have just as easily
done iris
and then in brackets target depending on
what i'm working on
both are acceptable let's go ahead and
run this code
and see how this changes and what we've
done is we've added the target
from the iris data set as another column
on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict
so we have our data which tells us the
answer for all these different pieces
and then we've added a column with the
answer that way when we do
our final setup we'll have the ability
to program our neural network to look
for these
this different data and know what a
setosa is or
a vera color which we'll see in just a
minute or virginica those are the three
that are in there and now we're going to
add
one more column i know we're organizing
all this data over and over again it's
kind of fun
there's a lot of ways to organize it
what's nice about putting everything
onto
one data frame is i can then do
a print out and it shows me exactly what
i'm looking at and i'll show you that
where you where that's different where
you can alter that and do it slightly
differently
but let's go ahead and put this into our
script up to that
now and here we go we're going to put
that down here
and we're going to run that and let's
talk a little bit about what we're doing
now we're exploring data and
one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model is
did your model work and to do this we
need to split the data and we split it
into
two different parts they usually call it
the training and the testing
and so in here we're going to go ahead
and put that in our database so you can
see it clearly
and we've set it df remember you can put
brackets this is creating another column
is train so we're going to use part of
it for training and this equals
np remember that stands for numpy dot
random dot uniform
so we're generating a random number
between 0
and 1 and we're going to do it for each
of the rows that's where the length df
comes from so each row gets a generated
number
and if it's less than 0.75 it's true
and if it's greater than 0.75 it's false
this means we're going to take 75
percent of the data
roughly because there's a randomness
involved and we're going to use that to
train it
and then the other 25 we're going to
hold off to the side
and use that to test it later on so
let's flip back on over and see what the
next step is
so now that we've labeled our database
for which is training and which is
testing
let's go ahead and sort that into two
different variables
train and test and let's take this code
and let's bring it into our project
and here we go let's paste it on down
here and before i run this
let's just take a quick look at what's
going on here is we have
up above we created remember there's our
def dot head which prints the first five
rows and we've added a column
is train at the end and so we're going
to take that we're going to create
two variables we're going to create two
new data frames one's called
train one's called test 75
in train 25 in test and then to sort
that out
we're going to do that by doing df our
main original data frame with the iris
data in it
and if df is trained equals true
that's going to go in the train and if
df is trained equals false it goes in
the test
and so when i run this we're going to
print out the number in each one
let's see what that looks like and
you'll see that it puts 118 in the
training module
and it puts 32 in the testing module
which lets us know that there was 150
lines of data in here so if you went and
looked at the original data you could
see that there's 150 lines
and that's roughly 75 and one and 25
for us to test our model on afterward so
let's jump back to our code and see
where this goes in the next two steps
we want to do one more thing with our
data and that's make it readable to
humans
i don't know about you but i hate
looking at zeros and ones
so let's start with the features and
let's go ahead and
take those and make those readable to
humans and let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in and
you'll see here we've done
a couple very basic things we know
that the columns in our data frame
again this is a panda thing the df
columns
and we know the first four of them 0 1 2
3 that'd be the first four are going to
be the features or the titles of those
columns
and so when i run this you'll see down
here that it creates an index
sepa length sepa width pedal length and
pedal width
and this should be familiar because if
you look up here here's our column
titles going across and here's the first
four
one thing i want you to notice here is
that when you're in a command line
whether it's jupiter notebook or
you're running command line in the
terminal window
if you just put the name of it it'll
print it out this is the same as doing
print
features and the short hand is you just
put features in here
if you're actually writing a code and
saving the script and running it by
remote
you really need to put the print in
there but for this when i run it you'll
see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features
because it doesn't really matter and
this is one of the fun thing about
jupiter notebooks is i'm just building
the code as we go
and then we need to go ahead and create
the labels for the other part so let's
take a look and see what that
for our final step in prepping our data
before we actually start running the
training and the testing
is we're going to go ahead and convert
the species on here
into something the computer understands
so let's put this code into our script
and see where that takes us
all right here we go we've set y equal
to pd.factorize
train species of zero
so let's break this down just a little
bit we have our pandas
right here pd factorize what's
factorized doing i'm going to come back
to that in just a second
let's look at what train species is and
why we're looking
at the group zero on there and let's go
up here
and here is our species
remember this on that we created this
whole column here for species
and then it has setosa setosa setosa and
if you scroll down enough you'd also see
virginica and veracolor we need to
convert that into something the computer
understands zeros and ones
so the trained species of zero
because this is in the format of a of an
array of arrays
so you have to have the zero on the end
and then species
is just that column factorize goes in
there and looks at the fact
that there's only three of them so when
i run this you'll see that y
generates an array that's equal to in
this case it's the training set
and it's zeros ones and twos
representing the three different kinds
of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally
we get to actually start doing the
predicting so here we go
uh we have two lines of code oh my
goodness that was a lot of work to get
to two lines of code but there is a lot
in these two lines of code so let's take
a look and see what's going on here and
put this into
our full script that we're running and
let's paste this in here
and let's take a look and see what this
is we have we're creating a variable
clf and we're going to set this equal to
the random
forest classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with
as far as these two are concerned
they're very standard in
jobs all that does is to prioritize it
not something to really worry about
usually when you're doing this on your
own computer you do in jobs equals two
if you're working in a larger or big
data and you need to prioritize it
differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to run across the system
and things like that
and then the random state is just how it
starts zero is fine for here
but uh let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more
clf dot fit so we're fitting
we're training it we are actually
creating our
random forest classifier right here this
is the code that does everything and
we're going to take our training set
remember we kept our test off to the
side and we're going to take our
training set
with the features and then we're going
to go ahead and put that in
and here's our target the y so the y is
0 1 and 2
that we just created and the features is
the actual data going in
that we put into the training set let's
go ahead and run that
and this is kind of an interesting thing
because it printed out
the random force classifier
and everything around it and so when
you're running this
in your terminal window or in a script
like this
this automatically treats us like just
like when we were up here
and i typed in y and printed out y
instead of print y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out
but if you're actually running your code
that wouldn't be the case
and what is printed out is it shows us
all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals two
you can see the random state equals zero
those are the two that we sent in there
you would really have to dig deep to
find out all these
different meanings of all these
different settings on here some of them
are self-explanatory if you kind of
think about it a little bit like max
features is auto so all the features
that we're putting in there is just
going to
automatically take all four of them
whatever we send it it'll take some of
them might have so many features because
you're processing words there might be
like
1.4 million features in there because
you're doing legal documents and that's
how many different words are in there
at that point you probably want to limit
the maximum features that you're going
to process
and leaf nodes that's the end nodes
remember we had the fruit and we're
talking about the leaf nodes like i said
there's a lot in this
we're looking at a lot of stuff here so
you might have in this case there's
probably only think three leaf nodes
maybe four
you might have thousands of leaf nodes
at which point you do need to put a cap
on that and say okay it only goes so far
and then we're going to use all of our
resources on processing this
and that really is what most of these
are about is
limiting the process and making sure we
don't
overwhelm a system and there's some
other settings in here
again we're not going to go over all of
them warm start equals false
warm start is if you're programming it
one piece at a time externally
since we're not we're not going to have
like we're not going to continually
train this particular learning tree and
again like i said there's a lot
of things in here that you'll want to
look up more detail from the sk
learn and if you're digging in deep and
running a major project on here
for today though all we need to do is
fit or train our features and our target
y
so now we have our training model what's
next
if we're going to create a model we now
need to test it
remember we set aside the test feature
test group 25 of the data so let's go
ahead and take this code and let's put
it into
our script and see what that looks like
okay here we go
and we're going to run this
and it's going to come out with a bunch
of zeros ones and twos
which represents the three type of
flowers the setosa the virginica and the
versacolor
and what we're putting into our predict
is the test features
and i always kind of like to know what
it is i am looking at
so real quick we're gonna do test
features and remember features is an
array
of sepal length simple width pedal
length pedal width
so when we put it in this way it
actually loads all these different
columns that we loaded into features
so if we did just features let me just
do features in here seeing what features
looks like
this is just playing with the with
pandas data frames
you'll see that it's an index so when
you put an index in like this
into test features into test
it then takes those columns and creates
a panda data frames from those columns
and in this case we're going to go ahead
and put those into our predict
so we're going to put each one of these
lines of data
the 5.0 3.4 1.5.2
and we're going to put those in and
we're going to predict what our
new forest classifier is going to come
up with and this is
what it predicts it predicts zero zero
zero one two one one two two two
and and uh again this is the
flower type setosa virginica and
versacolor
so now that we've taken our test
features
let's explore that let's see exactly
what that data means to us
so the first thing we can do with our
predicts is we can actually generate
a different prediction model when i say
different we're going to view it
differently
it's not that the data itself is
different so let's take this next piece
of code and put it into our script
so we're pasting it in here and you'll
see that we're doing
predict and we've added underscore proba
for probability
so there's our clf.predict probability
so
we're running it just like we ran it up
here but this time
with this we're going to get a slightly
different result and we're only going to
look at the first 10.
so you'll see down here instead of
looking at all of them which was
what 27 you'll see right down here that
this generates a much larger
field on the probability and let's take
a look and see what that looks like
and what that means so when we do the
predict
underscore prabha for probability it
generates
three numbers so we had three leaf nodes
at the end and if you remember from all
the theory we did
this is the predictors the first one is
predicting
a 1 for setosa it predicts
a 0 for virginica and it predicts a 0
for versa color and so on and so on and
so on and let's um you know what i'm
going to change this just a little bit
let's look at 10 to 20
just because we can and we start to get
a little different of data
and you'll see right down here it gets
to this one this line right here
and this line has 0 0.5 0.5
and so if we're going to vote and we
have two equal votes it's going to go
with the first one
so it says uh setosa gets zero votes
virginica gets .5 votes
versacolor gets 0.5 votes but let's just
go with the
virginica since these two are equal and
so on and so on down the list you can
see how they vary on here
so now we've looked at both how to do a
basic predict of the features
and we've looked at the predict
probability let's see what's next on
here
so now we want to go ahead and start
mapping names for the plants
we want to attach names so that it makes
a little more sense for us
and this we're going to do in these next
two steps we're going to start
by setting up our predictions and
mapping them to the name so let's see
what that
looks like and let's go ahead and paste
that code in here
and run it and this goes along with the
next piece of code so we'll skip through
this quickly and then come back to a
little bit
so here's iris dot target names
and uh if you remember correctly this
was the
the names that we've been talking about
this whole time the setosa virginica
versus color
and then we're going to go ahead and do
the prediction again
we've run we could have just set a
variable equal to this instead of
re-running it each time but we're going
to run it again
clf dot predict test features remember
that
returns the zeros the ones and the twos
and then we're going to set that equal
to predictions so this time we're
actually putting it in a variable
and when i run this it distributes
it it comes out as an array and the
array is setosa satosa satosa satosa
setosa
we're only looking at the first five we
could actually do
let's do the first 25 just so we can see
a little bit more on there
and you'll see that it starts mapping it
to all the different flower types the
versa color and the virginica in there
and let's see how this goes with the
next one so let's take a look at the
top part of our species in here and
we'll take this code and put it in our
script
and let's put that down here and paste
it there we go and we'll go ahead and
run it
and let's talk about both these sections
of code here
and how they go together the first one
is our predictions and i went ahead and
did uh predictions through 25
let's just do five and so we have setosa
satoshi satosa satoshi that's what we're
predicting from
our test model and then we come down
here we look at test
species i remember i could have just
done test.species.head
and you'll see it says setosa satosa
setosa setosa
and they match so the first one is what
our forest is doing and the second one
is what the actual data is now is we
need to combine these so that we can
understand what that means we need to
know how good our forest is
how good it is at predicting the
features so that's where we come up to
the next step
which is lots of fun we're going to use
a single line of code
to combine our predictions and our
actuals so we have a nice chart to look
at
and let's go ahead and put that in our
script in our jupiter notebook here
let's see let's go ahead and paste that
in and then i'm going to
because i'm on the jupiter notebook i
can do a control minus so you can see
the whole line there
there we go resize it and let's take a
look and see what's going on here
we're going to create in pandas remember
pd stands for pandas
and we're doing a cross tab this
function takes two sets of data
and creates a chart out of them so when
i run it you'll get a nice chart down
here
and we have the predicted species
so across the top you'll see the setosa
versus color virginica
and the actual species setosa versacolor
virginica
and so the way to read this chart and
let's go ahead and take a look on how to
read this
chart here when you read this chart you
have setosa
where they meet you have versus color
where they meet and you have virginica
where they meet
and they're meeting where the actual and
the predicted agree
so this is the number of accurate
predictions so in this case it equals
30. if you had 13 plus 5 plus 12 you get
30. and then we notice here
where it says virginica but it was
supposed to be versacolor
this is inaccurate so now we have two
two inaccurate
predictions and 30 accurate predictions
so we'll say that the model accuracy is
93
that's just 30 divided by 32 and if we
multiply by 100
we can say that it is 93 percent
accurate so we have a 93
accuracy with our model i did want to
add one more quick thing in here on our
scripting
before we wrap it up so let's flip back
on over to my script
in here we're going to take this line of
code from up above
i don't know if you remember it but
predix equals the iris.target underscore
names
so we're going to map it to the names
and we're going to run the prediction
and we read it on test features
but you know we're not just testing it
we want to actually deploy it
so at this point i would go ahead and
change this
and this is an array of arrays this is
really important when you're running
these to know that
so you need the double brackets and i
could actually create
data maybe let's just do two flowers so
maybe i'm processing more data coming in
and we'll put two flowers in here and
then
i actually want to see what the answer
are is so let's go ahead and
type in preds and print that out and
when i run this
you'll see that i've now predicted two
flowers that maybe i measured in my
front yard as
versacolor and versacolor
not surprising since i put the same data
in for each one
this would be the actual end product
going out to be used on data that you
don't know the answer for
so that's going to conclude our
scripting part of this
introducing naive bayes classifier have
you ever wondered how your mail provider
implements spam filtering
or how online news channels perform news
text classification or
how companies perform sentimental
analysis of their audience on social
media
all of this and more is done through a
machine learning algorithm called
naive bayes classifier welcome to naive
bayes tutorial
my name is richard kirschner i'm with
the simply learn team
that's www.simplylearn.com get certified
get ahead what's in it for you we'll
start with what is naive bayes
a basic overview of how it works we'll
get into naive bayes and machine
learning where it fits in with our other
machine learning tools
why do we need naive bayes and
understanding naive bayes classifier
a much more in depth of how the math
works in the background finally we'll
get into the advantages of the nave
bayes classifier in the machine learning
setup and then
we'll roll up our sleeves and do my
favorite part we'll actually do some
python coding
and do some text classification using
the naive bayes
what is naive bayes let's start with a
basic introduction to the bayes theorem
named after thomas bayes from the 1700s
who first coined this in the western
literature
naive bayes classifier works on the
principle of conditional probability as
given by the bayes theorem
before we move ahead let us go through
some of the simple concepts in the
probability that we will be using
let us consider the following example of
tossing two coins
here we have two quarters and if we look
at all the different
possibilities of what they can come up
as we get that they could come up as
head heads
come up as head tell tell head and tell
tell when doing the math
on probability we usually denote
probability as a p a capital p
so the probability of getting two heads
equals one fourth
you can see on our data set we have two
heads and this occurs once out of the
four
possibilities and then the probability
of at least one tail
occurs three quarters of the time you'll
see in three of the coin tosses we have
tails in them and out of four that's
three fourths
and then the probability of the second
coin being head
given the first coin is tail is one half
and the probability of getting two heads
given the first coin is a ahead
is one half we'll demonstrate that in
just a minute and show you how that math
works
now when we're doing it with two coins
it's easy to see but when you have
something more complex
you can see where these pro these
formulas really come in and work
so the bayes theorem gives us the
conditional probability of an event a
given another event b has occurred in
this case
the first coin toss will be b and the
second coin toss a
this can be confusing because we've
actually reversed the order of them
and go from b to a instead of a to b
you'll see this a lot when you work in
probabilities
the reason is we're looking for event a
we want to know what that is
so we're going to label that a since
that's our focus and then given another
event
b has occurred in the bayes theorem as
you can see on the left
the probability of a occurring given b
has occurred
equals the probability of b occurring
given a has occurred
times a probability of a over the
probability of b
this simple formula can be moved around
just like any algebra formula and we
could do the probability of
a after a given b times probability of b
equals the probability of b given a
times probability of a
you can easily move that around and
multiply it and divide it out
let us apply bayes theorem to our
example here we have our two quarters
and we'll notice that the first two
probabilities of getting two heads
and at least one tail we compute
directly off the data so you can easily
see that we have
one example hh out of four one fourth
and we have three with tails in them
giving us three quarters
or three four seventy five percent the
second condition
the second uh set three and four we're
gonna explore a little bit more in
detail now we stick to a simple example
with two coins because you can easily
understand the math
the probability of throwing a tail
doesn't matter what comes before it and
the same with the head
so it's still going to be 50 percent or
one half but when that come when that
probability gets more complicated let's
say you have a d6 dice or some other
instance
then this formula really comes in handy
but let's stick to the simple example
for now
in this sample space let a be the event
that the second coin is head
and b be the event that the first coin
is tells again we reversed it because we
want to know what the second event is
going to be so we're going to be
focusing on a
and we write that out as a probability
of a given b
and we know this from our formula that
that equals the probability of b
given a times the probability of a over
the probability of b
and when we plug that in we plug in the
probability of the first coin being
tails given the second coin is heads
and the probability of the second coin
being heads given the first coin
being over the probability of the first
coin being tails when we plug that data
in and we have the probability of the
first coin being tails given the second
coin is heads
times the probability of the second coin
being heads over
the probability of the first coin being
tails you can see it's a simple formula
to calculate we have one half times one
half
over one-half or one-half equals 0.5
or one-fourth so the bayes theorem
basically calculates the conditional
probability of the occurrence of an
event
based on prior knowledge of conditions
that might be related to the event we
will explore this in detail when we take
up an example of online shopping further
in this tutorial
understanding naive bayes and machine
learning like with any of our other
machine learning tools it's important to
understand
where the naive bayes fits in the
hierarchy so under the machine
learning we have supervised learning and
there is other things like unsupervised
learning there's also reward system this
falls under the supervised learning and
then under the supervisor's learning
there's classification
there's also regression but we're going
to be in the classification side
and then under classification is your
naive bayes let's go ahead and glance
into
where is naive bayes used let's look at
some of the use scenarios for it
as a classifier we use it in face
recognition is this cindy or is it not
cindy
or whoever or it might be used to
identify parts of the face that they
then feed into
another part of the face recognition
program this is the eye this is the nose
this is the mouth
weather prediction is it going to be
rainy or sunny medical recognition
news prediction it's also used in
medical diagnosis we might
diagnose somebody as either as high risk
or not as high risk
for cancer or heart disease or other
ailments
and news classification we look at the
google news and it says well is this
political
or is this world news or a lot of that's
all done with a naive bayes
understanding naive bayes classifier now
we already went through a basic
understanding
with the coins and the two heads and two
tails and head tail tail heads etc we're
going to do just a quick review on that
and remind you that the naive bayes
classifier is based on the bayes theorem
which gives a conditional probability of
event a
given event b and that's where the
probability of
a given b equals the probability of b
given a
times probability of a over probability
of b remember this is an algebraic
function so we can move these different
entities around we can multiply by the
probability of b
so it goes to the left hand side and
then we could divide by the probability
of a given b
and just as easily come up with a new
formula for the probability of b
to me staring at these algebraic
functions kind of gives me a slight
headache
it's a lot better to see if we can
actually understand how this data fits
together in a table
and let's go ahead and start applying it
to some actual data so you can see what
that looks like
so we're going to start with the
shopping demo problem statement and
remember we're going to solve this first
in table form so you can see what the
math looks like and then we're going to
solve it in python
and in here we want to predict whether
the person will purchase a product
are they going to buy or don't buy very
important if you're running a business
you want to know how to maximize your
profits or at least maximize the
purchase of the people coming into your
store
and we're going to look at a specific
combination of different
variables in this case we're going to
look at the day the discount and the
free delivery and you can see here under
the day we want to know whether it's
on the weekday you know somebody's
working they come in after work or
maybe they don't work weekend you can
see the bright colors coming down there
celebrating not being in work or holiday
and did we offer a discount that day yes
or no did we offer free delivery that
day yes or no
and from this we want to know whether
the person is going to buy based on
these traits
so we can maximize them and find out the
best system for getting somebody to come
in and purchase our goods and products
from our store
now having a nice visual is great but we
do need to dig into the data
so let's go ahead and take a look at the
data set we have a small sample data set
of 30 rows we're showing you the first
15 of those roads for this demo
now the actual data file you can request
just type in below under the comments on
the youtube video
and we'll send you some more information
and send you that file as you can see
here
the file is very simple columns and rows
we have the day
the discount the free delivery and did
the person purchase or not
and then we have under the day whether
it was a weekday a holiday
was it the weekend this is a pretty
simple set of data
and long before computers people used to
look at this data and calculate this all
by hand so let's go ahead and
walk through this and see what that
looks like we put that into tables
also note in today's world we're not
usually looking at three different
variables in 30 rows
nowadays because we're able to collect
data so much we're usually looking at
27 30 variables across hundreds of rows
the first thing we want to do is we're
going to take this data and
based on the data set containing our
three inputs day discount and free
delivery we're going to go ahead and
populate that to frequency tables for
each attribute
so we want to know if they had a
discount how many people
buy and did not buy did they have a
discount yes or no
do we have a free delivery yes or no on
those days how many people
made a purchase how many people didn't
and the same with the three days of the
week was it a weekday a weekend a
holiday
and did they buy yes or no as we dig in
deeper to this table
for our bayes theorem let the event buy
ba
now remember we looked at the coins i
said we really want to know what the
outcome is
did the person buy or not and that's
usually event a is what you're looking
for and the independent variables
discount free delivery and day bb so
we'll call that probability of b
now let us calculate the likelihood
table for one of the variables
let's start with day which includes
weekday weekend and holiday and
let us start by summing all of our rows
so we have the
weekday row and out of the weekdays
there's nine plus two so it's 11
weekdays
there's eight weekend days and 11
holidays
wow it's a lot of holidays and then we
want to sum up the total number of days
so we're looking at a total of 30 days
let's start pulling some information
from our chart and see where that takes
us
and when we fill in the chart on the
right you can see that
9 out of 24 purchases are made on the
weekday
7 out of 24 purchases on the weekend and
8 out of 24 purchases on a holiday and
out of all the people who come in 24 out
of 30 purchase
you can also see how many people do not
purchase on the weekdays two out of six
didn't purchase
and so on and so on we can also look at
the totals and you'll see on the right
we put together some of the formulas the
probability of making a purchase
on the weekend comes out 11 out of 30.
so out of the 30 people who came into
the store
throughout the weekend weekday and
holiday 11 of those purchases were made
on the weekday
and then you can also see the
probability of them
not making a purchase and this is done
for it doesn't matter which day of the
week
so we call that probability of no buy
would be 6 over 30 or 0.2 so there's a
20
chance that they're not going to make a
purchase no matter what day of the week
it is
and finally we look at the probability
of bfa
in this case we're going to look at the
probability of the weekday and not
buying two of the no buys were done out
of the weekend out of the six people who
did not make purchases
so when we look at that probability of
the weekday without a purchase
is going to be 0.33 or 33 percent let's
take a look at this at different
probabilities
and based on this likelihood table let's
go ahead and
calculate conditional probabilities as
below the first three we just did
the probability of making a purchase on
the weekday is 11 out of 30 or
roughly 36 or 37 percent 0.367
the probability of not making a purchase
at all doesn't matter what day of the
week
is roughly point two or twenty percent
and the probability
of a weekday no purchase is roughly two
out of six so two out of six of our no
purchases were made
on the weekday and then finally we take
our p of a
b if you look we've kept the symbols up
there we got p of
probability of b probability of a
probability of b if a
we should remember that the probability
of a if
b is equal to the first one times the
probability of no buys over the
probability of the weekday
so we could calculate it both off the
table we created we can also calculate
this by the formula
and we get the 0.367 which equals
or 0.33 times 0.2 over 0.367 which
equals 0.179
or roughly 17 to 18 percent and that'd
be the probability of
no purchase done on the weekday and this
is important
because we can look at this and say as
the probability of buying
on the weekday is more than the
probability of not buying on the weekday
we can conclude that customers will most
likely buy the product on a weekday
now we've kept our charts simple and
we're only looking at one aspect so you
should be able to look at the table and
come up with the same information or the
same conclusion that should be kind of
intuitive at this point
next we can take the same setup we have
the frequency tables of all three
independent variables
now we can construct the likelihood
tables for all three
of the variables we're working with we
can take our day
like we did before we have weekday
weekend and holiday we filled in this
table and then we can come in and also
do that for the discount
yes or no did they buy yes or no and we
fill in that full table so
now we have our probabilities for
a discount and whether the discount
leads to a purchase or not
and the probability for free delivery
does that lead to a purchase or not
and this is where it starts getting
really exciting let us use these three
likelihood tables to calculate whether a
customer will purchase a product on a
specific combination of
day discount and free delivery or not
purchase
here let us take a combination of these
factors day equals holiday
discount equals yes free delivery equals
yes
let's dig deeper into the math and
actually see what this looks like
and we're going to start with looking
for the probability of them
not purchasing on the following
combinations of days we're actually
looking for
the probability of a equal no buy no
purchase
and our probability of b we're going to
set equal to is it a holiday
did they get a discount yes and was it a
free delivery yes
before we go further let's look at the
original equation the probability of
a if b equals the probability of b
given the condition a and the
probability times probability of a
over the probability of b occurring now
this is basic
algebra so we can multiply this
information together so when you see the
probability of
a given b in this case the condition
is b c and d or the three different
variables we're looking at
and when you see the probability of b
that would be the conditions we're
actually going to multiply those three
separate conditions out probability of
you'll see that in a second in the
formula
times the full probability of a over the
full probability of b
so here we are back to this and we're
going to have let a equal
no purchase and we're looking for the
probability of b
on the condition a where a sets for
three different things
remember that equals the probability of
a given the condition
b and in this case we just multiply
those three different
variables together so we have the
probability of the discount
times the probability of free delivery
times the probability is the day
equal a holiday those are our three
variables of the probability
of a if b and then that is going to be
multiplied by the probability of them
not making a purchase and then we want
to divide that by the total
probabilities
and they're multiplied together so we
have the probability of a discount
the probability of a free delivery and
the probability of it being on a holiday
when we plug those numbers in we see
that one out of six were no purchase on
a discounted day
two out of six were no purchase on a
free delivery day
and three out of six were a no purchase
on a holiday
those are three probabilities of afb
multiplied out
and then that has to be multiplied by
the probability of a no purchase
and remember the prop probability of a
no buy is across
all the data so that's where we get the
6 out of 30. we divide that
out by the probability of each category
over the total number so we get the 20
out of 30 had a discount
23 out of 30 had a yes for free delivery
and 11 out of 30 were on a holiday we
plug all those numbers in we get
0.178 so in our probability math
we have a 0.178 if it's a no buy for a
holiday
a discount and a free delivery let's
turn that around and see what that looks
like if we have a purchase
i promise this is the last page of math
before we dig into the python script
so here we're calculating the
probability of the purchase using the
same math we did to find out if they
didn't buy
now we want to know if they did buy and
again we're going to go by the day
equals a holiday
discount equals yes free delivery equals
yes and let a
equal buy now right about now you might
be asking why are we doing both
calculations
why why would we want to know the no
buys and buys for the same data going in
well we're going to show you that in
just a moment but we have to have both
of those pieces of information
so that we can figure it out as a
percentage as opposed to a probability
equation
and we'll get to that normalization here
in just a moment let's go ahead and walk
through this calculation
and as you can see here the probability
of a on the condition of b
b being all three categories did we have
a discount
with a purchase do we have a free
delivery with a purchase and did we is a
day equal to holiday and when we plug
this all into that formula
and multiply it all out we get our
probability of a discount
probability of a free delivery
probability of the day being a holiday
times the overall probability of it
being a purchase
divided by again multiplying the three
variables out
the full probability of there being a
discount the full probability of being a
free delivery
and the full probability of there being
a day equal holiday and that's where we
get this 19 over 24
times 21 over 24 times 8 over 24
times the p of a 24 over 30
divided by the probability of the
discount the free delivery times a day
or 20 over 30 23 over 30 times 11 over
30
and that gives us our 0.986
so what are we going to do with these
two pieces of data we just generated
well let's go ahead and go over them we
have a probability of purchase
equals 0.986 we have a probability of
no purchase equals 0.178
so finally we have a conditional
probabilities of purchase on this day
let us take that we're going to
normalize it and we're going to take
these probabilities
and turn them into percentages this is
simply done
by taking the sum of probabilities which
equals 0.98686
plus 0.178 and that equals the 1.164
if we divide each probability by the sum
we get the percentage and so the
likelihood of a purchase
is 84.71 percent and the likelihood of
no purchase
is 15.29 given these three different
variables so it's if it's on a holiday
if it's a with a discount and has free
delivery then there's an 84.71
chance that the customer is going to
come in and make a purchase hooray
they purchased our stuff we're making
money if you're owning a shop that's
like is the bottom line is you want to
make some money so you can keep your
shop open and have a living
now i promised you that we were going to
be finishing up the math here
with a few pages so we're going to move
on and we're going to do two steps
the first step is i want you to
understand why
you want to under why you want to use
the naive bayes what are the advantages
of naive bayes
and then once we understand those
advantages we'll just look at that
briefly then we're going to dive in
and do some python coding advantages of
naive bayes classifier
so let's take a look at the six
advantages of the naive
bayes classifier and we're going to walk
around this lovely wheel looks like an
origami folded paper
the first one is very simple and easy to
implement certainly you could walk
through the tables and do this by hand
you got to be a little careful because
the notations can get confusing you have
all these different probabilities and i
certainly mess those up as i put them on
you know is it
on the top of the bottom got to really
pay close attention to that
when you put it into python it's really
nice because you don't have to worry
about any of that you let the python
handle that the python module but
understanding it you can put it on a
table and you can easily see how it
works and it's a simple algebraic
function
it needs less training data so if you
have smaller amounts of data this is
great powerful tool for that
handles both continuous and discrete
data it's highly scalable with number of
predictors and data points
so as you can see you just keep
multiplying different probabilities in
there and you can cover
not just three different variables or
sets you can now expand this to even
more categories
number five it's fast it can be used in
real time
predictions this is so important this is
why it's used in a lot of our
predictions on online shopping carts
uh referrals spam filters is because
there's no time delay as it has to go
through and figure
out a neural network or one of the other
mini setups where you're doing
classification
and certainly there's a lot of other
tools out there in the machine learning
that can handle these
but most of them are not as fast as the
naive bayes
and then finally it's not sensitive to
irrelevant features
so it picks up on your different
probabilities and if you're short on
date on one probability
you can kind of it automatically adjust
for that those formulas are very
automatic
and so you can still get a very solid
predictability
even if you're missing data or you have
overlapping data for two completely
different areas
we see that a lot in doing census and
studying of people and habits
where they might have one study that
covers one aspect another one that
overlaps and because the two overlap
they can then predict
the unknowns for the group that they
haven't done the second study on or vice
versa so it's very powerful in that it
is not sensitive to the irrelevant
features and in fact you can use it to
help
predict features that aren't even in
there so now we're down to my favorite
part
we're going to roll up our sleeves and
do some actual programming we're going
to do the use case
text classification now i would
challenge you to go back
and send us a note on the notes below
underneath the
video and request the data for the
shopping cart
so you can plug that into python code
and do that on your own time so you can
walk through it since we walk through
all the information on it but we're
going to do a python code
doing text classification very popular
for doing the naive bayes
so we're going to use our new tool to
perform a text classification of news
headlines and classify news into
different topics for a news website
as you can see here we have a nice image
of the google news
and then related on the right subgroups
i'm not sure where they actually pulled
the actual data we're going to use from
it's one of the standard sets
but certainly this can be used on any of
our news headlines in classification
so let's see how it can be done using
the naive bayes classifier
now we're at my favorite part we're
actually going to write some python
script
roll up our sleeves and we're going to
start by doing our imports
these are very basic imports including
our news group and we'll take a quick
glance at the target names
then we're going to go ahead and start
training our data set and putting it
together
we'll put together a nice graph because
it's always good to have a graph to show
what's going on
and once we've traded it and we've shown
you a graph of what's going on
then we're going to explore how to use
it and see what that looks like
now i'm going to open up my favorite
editor or inline editor for python
you don't have to use this you can use
whatever your editor that you like
whatever
interface ide you want this just happens
to be the anaconda
jupiter notebook and i'm going to paste
that first piece of code in here
so we can walk through it let's make it
a little bigger on the screen so you
have a nice view of what's going on
and we're using python 3 in this case
3.5
so this would work in any of your 3x if
you have it set up correctly it should
also work in a lot of the 2x
you just have to make sure all of the
versions of the modules match your
python version
and in here you'll notice the first line
is your percentage
matte plot library in line now three of
these lines of code are all about
plotting the graph this one lets
the notebook notes as an inline setup
that we want the graphs to show up
on this page without it in a notebook
like this which is an
explorer interface it won't show up now
a lot of ides don't require that
a lot of them like on if i'm working on
one of my other setups
it just has a pop-up and the graph pops
up on there so you have
that setup also but for this we want the
matplot library
inline and then we're going to import
numpy as
np that's number python which has a lot
of different formulas in it
that we use for both of our sklearn
module
and we also use it for any of the upper
math functions in python and it's very
common to see that as
np numpy as np the next two lines
are all about our graphing remember i
said three of these were about graphing
well we need our matplot library dot pi
plot as plt
and you'll see that plt is a very common
setup as is the sns
and just like the np and we're going to
import seaborn as
sns and we're going to do the sns.set
now seaborn sits on top of pi plot
and it just makes a really nice heat map
it's really good for heat maps and if
you're not familiar with heat maps that
just means we give it a color scale
the term comes from the brighter red it
is the hotter it is
in some form of data and you can set it
to whatever you want
and we'll see that later on so those
you'll see that those three lines of
code here are just importing the graph
function so we can graph it
and as a data science test you always
want to graph your data and have some
kind of visual
it's really hard just to shove numbers
in front of people and they look at it
and it doesn't mean anything
and then from the sklearn.datasets we're
going to import the fetch 20 news groups
very common one for analyzing tokenizing
words and setting them up and exploring
how the words work and how do you
categorize different things when you're
dealing with documents
and then we set our data equal to fetch
20 news groups so our data variable will
have the data in it
and we're going to go ahead and just
print the target names data.target names
and let's see what that looks like
and you'll see here we have alt atheism
comp graphics comp os ms windows dot
miscellaneous
and it goes all the way down to talk
politics dot miscellaneous talk religion
dot miscellaneous
these are the categories they've already
assigned to this
news group and it's called fetch 20
because you'll see there's i believe
there's 20 different topics in here or
20 different categories
as we scroll down now we've gone through
the 20 different categories and we're
going to go ahead
and start defining all the categories
and set up our data
so we're actually getting here going to
go ahead and get it get the data all set
up and take a look at our data
and let's move this over to our jupyter
notebook and let's see what this code
does
first we're going to set our categories
now if you noticed up here i could have
just as easily set this equal to
data.target underscore names because
it's the same thing
but we want to kind of spell it out for
you so you can see the different
categories
it kind of makes it more visual so you
can see what your data is looking like
in the background
once we've created the categories we're
going to open up a train
set so this training set of data is
going to go into fetch 20 news groups
and it's a subset in there
called train and categories equals
categories so we're pulling out those
categories that match
and then if you have a train set you
should also have the testing set we have
test equals fetch 20 news groups subset
equals test
and categories equals categories let's
go down one size so it all fits on my
screen
there we go and just so we can really
see what's going on let's see what
happens when we print out
one part of that data so it creates
train
and under train it creates train dot
data and we're just going to look at
data piece number five
and let's go ahead and run that and see
what that looks like and you can see
when i print train
dot data number five under train it
prints out one of the articles this is
article number five you can go through
and read it on there
and we can also go in here and change
this to test which should look identical
because it's splitting the date up into
different groups train and test
and we'll see test number five is a
different article but it's another
article in here
and maybe you're curious and you want to
see just how many articles are in here
we could do
length of train dot data
and if we run that you'll see that the
training data has
11 314 articles
so we're not going to go through all
those articles that's a lot of articles
but
we can look at one of them just you can
see what kind of information is coming
out of it and what we're looking at
and we'll just look at number five for
today and here we have it rewording the
second amendment ids vtt
line 58 lines 58 in article
etc and you can scroll all the way down
and see all the different parts to there
now we've looked at it and that's pretty
complicated when you look at one of
these articles to try to figure out how
do you
weight this if you look down here we
have different words and maybe the word
from
well from is probably in all the
articles so it's not going to have a lot
of
meaning as far as trying to figure out
whether this article fits one of the
categories or not
so trying to figure out which category
it fits in based on these words is where
the challenge comes in
now that we've viewed our data we're
going to dive in and do the actual
predictions
this is the actual naive bayes and we're
going to throw another model at you or
another module at you here in just a
second we can't go into too much detail
but it deals specifically working with
words and text
and what they call tokenizing those
words so
let's take this code and let's uh skip
on over to our jupiter notebook
and walk through it and here we are in
our jupiter notebook let's paste that in
there
and i can run this code right off the
bat it's not actually going to display
anything yet but it has a lot going on
in here
so the top we had the print module from
the earlier one i didn't know why that
was in there
so we're going to start by importing our
necessary packages
and from the sklearn features extraction
dot
text we're going to import tf idf
vectorizer i told you we're going to
throw a module at you
we can't go too much into the math
behind this or how it works you can look
it up the
notation for the math is usually tf.idf
and that's just a way of weighing the
words and it weighs the words based on
how many times they're used in a
document how many times
or how many documents they're used in
and it's a well used formula that's been
around for a while
it's a little confusing to put this in
here uh but let's
let her know that it just goes in there
and waits the different words in the
document for us
that way we don't have to wait and if
you put a weight on it if you remember i
was talking about that up here earlier
if these are all emails they probably
all have the word from in them
from probably has a very low weight it
has very little value in telling you
what this document's about
same with words like in an article in
articles n
cost of on maybe cost might or
where words like criminal weapons
destruction
these might have a heavier weight
because they describe a little bit more
what the article's doing
well how do you figure out all those
weights in the different articles
that's what this module does that's what
the tf idf vectorizer is going to do for
us
and then we're going to import our
sklearn.naive bayes
and that's our multinomial nb
multinomial
naive bayes pretty easy to understand
that where that comes from and then
finally we have the skylearn
pipeline pipeline import make pipeline
now the make pipeline is just a cool
piece of code
because we're going to take the
information we get from the tfidf
vectorizer
and we're going to pump that into the
multinomial nb
so a pipeline is just a way of
organizing how things flow
it's used commonly you probably already
guess what it is if you've done any
businesses they talk about the sales
pipeline
if you're on a work crew or project
manager you have your pipeline of
information that's going through or your
projects and what has to be done in what
order
that's all this pipeline is we're going
to take the tfid vectorizer and then
we're going to push that
into the multinomial nb now
we've designated that as the variable
model we have our pipeline model
and we're going to take that model and
this is just so elegant this is done in
just a couple lines of code
model.fit and we're going to fit the
data
and first the train data and then the
train
target now the train data has the
different articles in it
you can see the one we were just looking
at and the train dot
target is what category they already
categorized that
that particular article has and what's
happening here
is the train data is going into the tf
id vectorizer
so when you have one of these articles
that goes in there it weights
all the words in there so there's
thousands of words with different
weights on them i remember once
running a model on this and i literally
had 2.4
million tokens go into this so when
you're doing like
large document bases you can have a huge
number of different words
it then takes those words gives them a
weight and then
based on that weight based on the words
and the weights and then puts that into
the multinomial
nb and once we go into our naive bayes
we want to put the train target in there
so the trained data that's been
mapped to the tfid vectorizer is now
going through the multinomial in b and
then we're telling it well these are the
answers
these are the answers to the different
documents so this document that has all
these words with these different weights
from the first part is going to be
whatever category it comes out of maybe
it's the
talk show or the article on religion
miscellaneous
once we fit that model we can then take
labels
and we're going to set that equal to
model.predict
most of the sklearn used the term dot
predict to let us know that we've now
trained the model and now we want to get
some answers and we're going to put our
test data in there
because our test data is the stuff we
held off to the side
we didn't train it on there and we don't
know what's going to come up out of it
and we just want to find out how good
our labels are do they match what they
should be
now i've already run this through
there's no actual output to it to show
this is just setting it all up this is
just training our model
creating the labels so we can see how
good it is and then we move on to the
next step to find out what happened
to do this we're going to go ahead and
create a confusion matrix
and a heat map so the confusion matrix
which is confusing just by its very name
is basically going to ask
how confused is our answer did it get it
correct
or did it miss some things in there or
have some mis labels
and then we're going to put that on a
heat map so we'll have some nice colors
to look at to see how that plots out
let's go ahead and take this code and
see how that take a walk through it and
see what that looks like
so back to our jupiter notebook and put
the code in there
and let's go ahead and run that code
take it just a moment and remember we
had the inline that way my graph
shows up on the inline here and let's
walk through the code and then we'll
look at this and see what that means
so make it a little bit bigger there we
go no reason not to use a whole screen
too big
so we have here from sk learn metrics
import confusion matrix
and that's just going to generate a set
of data that says
i the prediction was such the actual
truth was either agreed with it or is
something different
and it's going to add up those numbers
so we can take a look and just see how
well it worked
and we're going to set a variable mat
equal to confusion matrix
we have our test target our test data
that was not part of the training
very important in data science we always
keep our test data separate
otherwise it's not a valid model if we
can't properly test it with new data
and this is the labels we created from
that test data these are the ones that
we predict it's going to be
so we go in and we create our sn heat
map the sns
is our seaborn which sits on top of the
pie plot
so we create a sns dot heat map
we take our confusion matrix and it's
going to be
mat dot t and do we have other
variables that go into the sns.heat map
we're not going to go into detail what
all the variables mean the annotation
equals true that's what tells it to put
the numbers here so you have the 166 the
one the zero zero zero one
format d and c bar equals false have to
do with the
format if you take those out you'll see
that some things disappear
and then the x tick labels and the y
tick labels those are our target names
and you can see right here that's the
alt atheism
comp graphics comp osms windows dot
miscellaneous
and then finally we have our plt dot x
label
remember the sns or the seaborn sits on
top of our matplot library our plt
and so we want to just tell that x label
equals a true is is true the labels are
true and then the
y label is prediction label so we say a
true
this is what it actually is and the
prediction
is what we predicted and let's look at
this graph because that's probably a
little confusing the way we rattled
through it
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
go ahead and flip back to
the slides because they have a black
background they put in there that helps
it shine a little bit better so you can
see the graph a little bit easier
so in reading this graph what we want to
look at is how the color scheme
has come out and you'll see a line right
down
the middle diagonally from upper left to
bottom right
what that is is if you look at the
labels we have our predicted label
on the left and our true label on the
right those are the numbers where the
prediction
and the true come together and this is
what we want to see is we want to see
those lit up that's what that heat map
does
as you can see that it did a good job of
finding those data
and you'll notice that there's a couple
of red spots on there were missed you
know
it's a little confused we talk about
talk religion miscellaneous
versus talk politics miscellaneous
social religion christian
versus alt atheism it mislabeled some of
those
and those are very similar topics so you
could understand why it might mislabel
them
but overall it did a pretty good job if
we're going to create these models
we want to go ahead and be able to use
them so let's see what that looks like
to do this let's go ahead and create a
definition
a function to run and we're going to
call this function let me just expand
that just a notch here there we go
i like mine in big letters predict
categories we want to predict the
category
we're going to send it s a string and
then
we're sending it train equals train we
have our training model
and then we had our pipeline model
equals model this way we don't have to
resend these variables each time
the definition knows that because i said
train equals train and i put the equal
for model
and then we're going to set the
prediction equal to the model.predict
s so it's going to send whatever string
we send
to it it's going to push that string
through the pipeline the model pipeline
it's going to go through and tokenize it
and put it through the
tf idf convert that into numbers and
weights for all the different documents
and words
and then i'll put that through our naive
bayes
and from it we'll go ahead and get our
prediction we're going to predict what
value it is
and so we're going to return train dot
target names predict
of zero and remember that the train dot
target names that's just categories
i could have just as easily put
categories in there
dot predict of zero so we're taking the
prediction which is a number and we're
converting it to an actual category
we're converting it from i don't know
what the actual numbers are but let's
say zero equals alt atheism
so we're going to convert that zero to
the word or one maybe it equals comp
graphics
so we're going to convert number one
into comp graphics that's all that is
and then we got to go ahead and and then
we need to go ahead
and run this so i load that up and then
once i
run that we can start doing some
predictions let me go ahead and type in
predict category
and let's just do predict category jesus
christ
and it comes back and says it's social
religion christian
that's pretty good now note i didn't put
print on this
one the nice things about the jupiter
notebook editor and a lot of inline
editors is if you just put the name
of the variable out as returning the
variable train.target underscore names
it'll automatically print that for you
in your own id
you might have to put in print let's see
where else we can take this
and maybe you're a space science buff so
how about
sending load to international
space station and if we run that
we get science space or
maybe you're a automobile buff and let's
do
oh they're going to tell me audi is
better than bmw but i'm going to do bmw
is better than an audi so maybe your car
buff
and we run that and you'll see it says
recreational i'm assuming that's what
rec
stands for autos so i did a pretty good
job labeling that one
how about uh if we have something like a
caption running through there
president of india and if we run that
it comes up and says talk politics
miscellaneous
so when we take our definition our
function and we run all these things
through
kudos we made it we were able to
correctly classify
texts into different groups based on
which category they belong to
using the naive bayes classifier now we
did throw in
the pipeline the tf idea vectorizer
we threw in the graphs those are all
things that you don't necessarily have
to know
to understand the naive bayes setup or
classifier
but they're important to know one of the
main uses for the naive bayes is
with the tf idf tokenizer vectorizer
where tokenizes the word
as labels and we use the pipeline
because
you need to push all that data through
and it makes it really easy and fast
you don't have to know those understand
naive bayes but they certainly help
for understanding the industry and data
science and we can see
our categorizer our naive bayes
classifier
we were able to predict the category
religion space
motorcycles autos politics and properly
classify
all these different things we pushed
into our prediction and our trained
model
welcome to simply learn's machine
learning engineer salary skills and
resume
who is a machine learning engineer a
machine learning engineer is someone who
performs the following tasks
develops and implements production-ready
algorithms and methods
this is a very difficult challenge
because we talk about production ready
that's a key word in here this is
something that's going to be pushed out
to end users to be able to use whether
it's a bank
doing their finances or your new
cell phone where it's doing some kind of
image adjustment and adding in
virtual images or stamps onto the
picture code evolves machine learning
solutions with data scientists
and engineers so you're going to be
working as a team the data scientists
are going to be developing this and then
you're going to be implementing it
provides technical guidance to product
teams on the choice of machine learning
approaches
appropriate for the task machine
learning engineers will design
implement and ship new algorithms
provides architectural guidance on
changing prototypes to high performance
production models
and provides feedback on tools and new
features required to send it back to the
development teams
so let's dig a little deeper into the
responsibilities of a machine learning
engineer
they study and transform data science
prototypes design
machine learning systems implement
machine learning algorithms
develop machine learning applications
select
appropriate data sets that is so huge in
the machine learning engineer
is how do you get these data sets in
there and how do you use the appropriate
ones
and that's going to go back and forth to
your data scientists as a machine
learning engineer you want to be able to
recommend stuff for them and then they
got to go back and prototype it and then
it comes back to you to put it together
and start training these neural networks
perform statistical analysis and
fine-tuning
and train and retrain systems when
necessary and that's also another big
one because there's a lot of upkeep on
these
if you've ever seen the evolution of any
of the
current ais out there from google voice
to all the different picture programs
and everything there's a continual
retraining of these systems going on
and they continually improve so they're
not just rebuilding the whole thing from
the bottom up
sometimes they're just retraining them
to get a better response what's most
exciting about this
and what most people are in here for is
going to be salary trends of a machine
learning engineer
so where does that fit in in the money
show me the money and we look at the
salary treatments
the salary trends of a machine learning
engineer we look at the average base pay
and this is for the us
it's 121 707 dollars and you can see
right there there's our average around
122 k
low end is 83k so if you're just getting
into the field and you're looking for
a apprenticeship kind of thing that's
where you start looking at 83k
and then once you have that high-end
expertise now you're looking at 162k
so it's got a really nice salary to it
in the us the average salary of a
machine learning engineer in the united
states
is 121 707 per year and if we look at
that
we skip over to india the average salary
of a machine learning engineer in india
is 750 000 per year 750 k
in indian standards and it ranges from
the lower
383 to 1584 k
and that's important to note that one of
the interesting things is in
india if you're coming in as an
apprentice you have a lot more room
to breathe there and there's more jobs
available where in the us it's a little
harder to get in at the beginning but
once you're in there once you get your
foot in the door
your salary just shoots up with you know
into the upper end
machine learning engineered jobs and
we're going to take this is just a pull
off of indeed's best jobs in the us
and comparing average base salary to
percentage growth in job postings 2015
to 2018
and this data was pulled back in march
of this year 2019.
and you can see here as we just kind of
go across there you can look at all the
different celeries going up
and certainly the machine learning
engineer is just
shot up because it's one of the primary
growing fields
and it's not stopping i mean this this
is we're in such an infant
stage of machine learning and training
and how do we get into these deep
learning models
so the graph shows the average base
salary versus a growth
in job postings from 2015 to 2018.
the red line indicates the growth in job
postings a machine learning engineer it
is observed
that machine learning engineer has a 344
percent
growth of job postings from 2015 to
2019.
again that's not going to stop that's
just going to keep rising because that
is
where a lot of the actual work is right
now
stuff is being pushed out they've got it
working now they need a machine learning
engineer to go in there and do all that
retraining and fine-tuning
and that's a huge job and it's it's a
growing industry it's just going to
continue to take off
so we look at top companies hiring for
machine learning engineers we got amazon
apple uh deloitte i hope i said that
right uber facebook
spotify google microsoft cisco
all of these should look for me these
are all the big tick companies and we're
starting to see it filter into the small
companies in fact i was just reading an
article that had one of the neural
networks that's used in deep learning
tensorflow
has a tensorflow lite that runs on an
adreno
board if you know anything about adreno
that is the 35
that's us dollar cheap computer in a box
that you can
build something and strap it on there
and actually run a really simple neural
network
obviously you're not going to be doing
some high-end graphics but you can
certainly use it for doing a lot of
little things
so across the board companies are hiring
machine learning engineers now
we look at the skills of a machine
learning engineer as we start looking
forward machine learning engineers
should have the following skills
one programming pick a program master it
if you don't already
you should have at least two solid
programs under your belt in machine
learning the top program right now is
python with the close following of java
there's also scala is very big
when we're talking about a lot of this
in any of these programs you should be
able to be really solid in one
programming skill
and be able to adapt to another one so
having a secondary one at least
should be important because you never
know when you walk into a job what
people want
the program might start in python and
indian scala and then they realize that
they need to
push it out onto the server and it's a
java code that they want
so and it's not as hard as you think to
switch between the codes but it does
require you have a little knowledge in
each of those codes and be a master of
one
applied mathematics you must have basic
understanding of math
and this is becoming less and less
important but it still you need to have
some fundamental knowledge of your
mathematics
data modeling and evaluation that is so
central to
what starts separating it from a
programmer or from a data scientist is
your data modeling and how to evaluate
these different models
so very important skill machine learning
algorithms and libraries
that's just the vocabulary it's a
vocabulary of data modeling and
evolution
machine learning algorithms and
libraries that's just the
language of data modeling and evaluation
you have to understand all the different
algorithms and libraries and what's
going on there so that you can model
different data and evaluate it under the
different models
so let's take a look at programming
programming ability to adapt
implement and make changes to the
programs when required
programming languages like c c plus plus
java python
r studio i didn't mention r because
that's also
one of the big data science programs
that are out there and again
right now python just topped the chart
our studio for data science
java's way up there cp any of these are
really hardcore
so master if you're if you have a master
and any of these great
you should know something and be able to
just glance into python and probably
glance a little bit into r is important
too
because those are the current data
science programs being used so you can
actually look at this and be able to
know what to pull and what to push
we talk about applied mathematics
understanding of matrixes
that's that's probably the thing that
trips a lot of people up in mathematics
even people who are pretty solid in
mathematics start looking at matrixes
and
uh they just start looking at columns
and rows and eyes go
dilated so understanding your matrixes
and being able to manipulate them
derivatives and integrals is necessary
so you have an understanding of your
basic derivative and what that means
statistical concepts like mean standard
deviation
is required you really need to know
those terminologies and what the
standard deviation means what
a square means any of those concepts
median versus mode
versus any of those things those are so
important when you're doing
applied mathematics and you're looking
at data science and
in this case the engineering side of it
and understanding of probability
algorithms like naive bayes
mixture models is required data modeling
and evaluation
data modeling is a process of finding
the hidden structure of a given data set
and finding patterns such as
correlations and clusters
a key part of the process is evaluating
how good a given model is in choosing an
appropriate accuracy error measure
and an evaluation strategy now one of
the things i find interesting in the
field
is that people start looking at the data
modeling and you can write a script that
goes through all the different models
and then you can take some of those
models and change all the different
underlying dimensions for that model
that takes up a lot of processing
so you might do that in very basic or
small part of your data set but as you
fine tune it
you start learning that understanding
the it's almost like a
kind of a the art form of data modeling
right now
is in this area is which how do you find
those correlations which cluster control
do you want
uh do you are you training it or are you
just finding things that match some of
these things go with some other things
you're just clustering it based on their
features understanding all that is is
really the art form digging into the
data science and data engineering side
and as a machine learning engineer
this is important to be able to
understand as we look at machine
learning algorithms and libraries
you need a firm understanding of
algorithm concepts like linear
regression support vector
machine k-means etc and understanding
how these algorithms work and so this is
kind of a re-hash of some of the other
things we saw earlier
and this is a vocabulary you need to
know this vocabulary you need to know
when you're looking at
a linear regression model versus just a
regression model what's the difference
you can't just throw one into the other
well actually you can
but if you throw one into the other you
don't get as good of a result
and then you waste a lot of time messing
with the wrong thing
and understanding your packages
libraries and apis like site kit learn
that's part of the mainly python
although it's spilling over and being
adapted in other areas
theno tensorflow pandas and numpy you
know all
huge packages currently being run for
the
machine learning algorithms to give you
an idea we'll go over to the the simply
learn website
and you can see data scientist here and
when you come in here you can see
there's a whole
series a lot of times we start with our
programming this isn't by
accident our programming is was the
standard of data science for so long so
you'll see data science sas
python data training sas has come in
that's a it's one of the major players
but it's not one of the big programming
languages um your python your machine
learning
again here's a more specific tableau
which is very highly used in the
industry
hadoop and spark important to have a
basics of big data again this is all
stuff as
that is going to come up if you're as a
data engineer or data scientist
and there's a lot of other ones here
including all the way through the master
programming so a lot of tools here that
you can look up and
set up as far as getting your skills up
to par
for being a machine learning engineer
and of course the bottom line is um
where's the money you know it's if we're
going to train depending on where you're
at in your career
a resume of machine learning engineer is
important to
understand and they've changed so much i
remember my first
we won't talk about how long ago my
first paper machine learning was my
first resume i put out
for work and job and applications
resumes have changed
so much and when we talk about something
like a machine learning engineer
they're going in leaps and bounds and
let's just go ahead and
pop open a quick template here and just
show you some ideas of what we're
looking at
so and i've opened this up into a simple
pdf
reader adobe acrobat reader one of the
first things
is that and this always catches me off
guard as we're starting to see where we
want to see the person
and you can actually put your photo on
the resume it stands out they're going
to remember you
you know wear a tie a suit and tie look
nice be a professional on this one but
that's a big thing now
it catches people eyes and we i've seen
that forever say in the real estate
industry they hand you their business
card
and it has their photo on it even back
in the 90s they didn't care long as they
had that visual
uh so we want a name a face an email id
contact number but we really want that
name in bold and we really want to see
who you are
this is such a shift from the way it
used to be
it used to be that you did not want your
personal stuff on your resume now you do
and of course the summary is very
important you can see right here
and again there's different options on
this so this format isn't necessarily
the only format you need to use
but this is a really good place to start
as you can see here we're actually using
almost a third of the page
to put your name put your summary and
this next part is another one
another huge one your linkedin profile
if you have it
um they start looking at that and you
have all you post all of your stuff on
there nowadays they ask you hey what's
your history what's your employment
history and they can go down with your
certifications
suddenly this linkedin has all this
massive amount of information that they
can go pull
and find out more about you without
having to go through the resume so the
resume is almost secondary at some point
and another really important shift we
see
is where's your github link or someplace
maybe you have a personal website um
someplace you can show
your skills in coding your skills and
what you do
so they no longer want to just have a
resume that says yeah i'm good
they want to actually see what you're
capable of this is a huge shift in
resumes today
and with that i'm going to give a quick
warning as a
as i come in there and i look up people
and they say hey do i want this person
to work for me
i'm going to do a search on them they're
going to do a search on your name when
you're looking for a job so remember
your facebook and all your personalized
stuff
if it is public make sure it's
professional you know you don't want to
have somebody go in there and decide
they don't like you because your
favorite
rock band is imagine dragons or
and also keep in mind that sometimes
those facebook posts
show up on somebody else's feed so even
though you think you're private remember
any of that stuff could end up public
and your employer might be looking at
that in some jobs you might want to
highlight that if your specialty is
marketing and you're using facebook and
marketing
put that in here uh so again it gives
them another link of what you do
and what you're doing on your resume we
come down to experience
this can go in different areas a lot of
times if you have
been in the programming industry for
years
you know i have over two decades as a
programmer this is almost a secondary
page sometimes
where i just have all the companies
listed that i've worked for
with the blurb about what i did for them
again a lot of people just go to
linkedin and they already see that
information so they're going to skip
right over it so you might even bump it
down to the bottom and then your
education and skills
in a lot of cases you might take your
skills and bump them to the top
highlight yourself and then have your
education certifications
again it depends on your history and
what your strength is
if you have very specific skills you're
highlighting you might want to bump this
to the top so the company
is aware of it but again we have a very
basic blurb experience
education skills certifications this
goes with education sometimes
arrange that that's going to highlight
you and show you off the best
so if you're really big on
certifications you might put those next
and just have two columns of all the
certifications you've gone through
and where they came from and then maybe
your education
maybe you have oh an associate's degree
so you might have 20 different
certifications
and a two-year associate's degree so the
education might go underneath your
certifications and so on again organize
this to
highlight you and your strengths and
also to target the company you're
looking for in a resume
i just love the switch over here on the
top and there's even another suggestion
you could even do
a personalized video again now they have
a this is a sales and marketing thing
we're starting to talk about where we
have a physical page they're looking at
hopefully you've talked to them on the
telephone so they have their voice in
the air
and a video would be a third input so
the more
the different inputs they have fourth
being the website
maybe a personal website would be fifth
if you have a facebook that's somewhat
you know professional on there and
addressing
and addressing what you're going after
put that stuff in here the more input
somebody gets
the more rounded they see you and the
more they might want to employ you as a
human being instead of just another page
on their stack of people to go through
and with that we have come to the end of
this video
i hope it was useful and informative if
you have any questions related to the
machine learning topics that were
covered in this video
then please put it in the chat section
our team will help you solve your
queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here